surprise cutscene what are you saying cutscene hello sorry we just started the game and there's a cutscene we didn't want you to miss the whole thing yeah at the time of the attack you had abandoned we're jumping right in yeah hi hello you're the one who plans all this with what evidence I need a recap.
I didn't realize they were going to throw us right in.
Oh, they look mad.
This is the guy.
You liar.
With the ring?
Wait, no.
Wait, yes?
I think so.
Green devils?
Is that him?
Yeah, this is the green devil.
And we just finished killing her sister.
It was her sister, right?
Oh, was it?
I think so.
Maybe you shouldn't have been looking at her.
bakery like that sorry sis um there's like no guys and we fought with uh i remember the lady yeah uh ada we fought with ada yeah and uh okay so recap we started in this city and helena here was like we gotta go to the chapel it'll tell you everything and so we finally get to the chapel after many many adventures and um and then we go in this underground bunker and then there's a secret lab yeah yeah yeah and then your sister is there and she transforms into a crazy nanky yeah she like gets reborn yeah which it seems like is what happened to Ada,
but Ada this time was like, no, not her.
No, Ada's like... Yeah, there was a tape that showed Ada, but she was like, mm-mm, I'm... I'm normal.
Yeah.
And then we called the green goblin.
Very angry.
No, I think we... So the lady that was next to him, she calls us, and then we're just like, hey, it's this guy's fault.
He's the one controlling you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then he's like, did someone mention me?
And...
and and now we stop the outbreak i don't think is there a stopping the outbreak then there wouldn't be resident evil 7 and 8 that's wasn't different there's a new outbreak every every game right yeah it must be flavor okay i have to remember how to play oh golly okay yeah how do i go through did we get like the green skills i think we held out on our money does that mean we have to wait yeah the next chapter i think so wait how do i get to my money or the my inventory oh gosh oh i only know the controller is it tab i tried tab we think i thought it Um...
Uh...
Yeah, Ada was aura farming.
I?
No, you think it would be I.
What was it?
Sorry.
A, B, C...
C...
Oh, C is dodge.
Wait, you can dodge?
It's E.
E for E inventory.
So right!
Wait, but I still don't remember how to use the grenades again.
Oh gosh, this is the word.
I remember the grenades.
Yeah, I can only...
Oh, I remember!
I think.
Oh yeah, grenade time.
Oh, are you ready?
I think so.
You got your knife out?
Oh yeah.
Yep, yep, yep.
Inventory.
okay good i was gonna say i didn't see anyone say plus two in the chat here oh we have this thing v okay oh gosh it's very indiana jones yeah sometimes
in downtown raccoon city but this isn't raccoon city right no we're in the boonies i don't know where we are oh yeah they said that they said it's like a town of like 500 people but but then it's like got all this stuff here yeah as long as you help me get to simmons oh it's skyrim are these zombies or look at these guys are sitting so proper they are wow i hear someone moaning and groaning oh a little history there huh it is it's the drago for sure
this guy he's trying to get a cab i don't think any cab's coming for him this is so goofy looking you really they're like pngs but it feels like like a family photo the way they're arranged you know yeah they're all like they have like their arms behind each other's backs they're going to prom together oh i heard some bones rattling oh i thought are we getting skeletons now first zombies now skeletons scott i don't know why they're so posed yeah wouldn't they fall over wait what did they muscles left?
Oh.
A vampire.
Vampire.
Need help?
Oh, oh.
This guy's got a gun!
Barry, but you hit by a assault rifle.
Oh my god.
A nice time comes.
Ye old assault rifle.
What?
That's crazy.
Oh, it's got a laser sight.
Oh, wait.
I think they all had laser sights.
Maybe I'm sorry.
in there yeah oh i thought i could shoot him down i don't think he's a well i don't think he is undead yeah i have to oh did i just step on a trap oh big saws big saws oopsie can you jump in this game i don't think so we can crouch though oh that's dodge
C is not for...
Oh, this is...
Oh, I got prompts.
Oh, oh.
Oh my god.
We're still getting the tutorial in chapter 3.
While dashing slide.
Oh, there was a dash.
I'm going!
Oh!
I'm sorry.
I'm going to the song.
It's okay, we each get one.
Okay.
Here I go!
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, there's zombies!
Ah!
Get up!
I can't get up!
Wait, it won't let me get up!
He's sidestepping.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
My mom is...
That way wasn't for me.
You had mine.
You took it.
Okay.
I don't like the songs.
What if I step back and shoot at them?
Okay, you can do that.
Yeah.
And then eventually, you'll walk through.
Yeah, I can.
Oh, gosh.
Keep going.
I'm crawling.
If you'll just cover me, yeah.
Thanks.
Okay, I got you.
How do I get up?
Okay, there we go.
Oh, wow.
You really got him good.
Okay.
All right, your turn.
I'm scared.
You got this.
oh
i'm clear i
think you're good i think you're good am i good yes it's like when you're on the water slide and you don't it's all the way down you have to scoot your butt yourself why does he walk like my app is at least crawling oh the music's so spooky oh my god who said this i can't anything where's the crosshair oh i got him nice there's a lot of flames oh yeah i don't know if we can um we have to dash through this too maybe oh i'm investigating that could leave more than a Get up there,
get up there.
Thank you.
Is that me?
Oh, that's my shadow.
Ew, there's like so many spiders in here.
Ew, gross.
Good luck.
Oh, no.
Whoa, that's a big ol' spike.
What happened?
Are you okay?
Explodes.
The red ones explode.
There's, oh, the red zombies.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Okay, other people tried crawling through here, but they weren't as good as me.
Why are they giant spiders?
Oh my god.
Skeletons weren't...
No.
Okay, I'm going down.
I'm just waiting.
Oh, what are you doing?
Oh, he's...
Oh!
It's off!
He was...
There was a zombie cranking it here.
Excuse me?
There's a crank right here!
And he was doing it!
You just cranking it?
Yeah!
Well, I'm glad you stopped him.
Wait, if I do it again then...
Wait, ooh...
Oh!
Oh, yeah!
Whoa!
Interesting.
How do I stop?
Okay.
It's a good workout.
It is, it is.
Don't do it.
I'm over here.
I'm going, I'm going.
Wait, what is this thing?
I don't know.
Oh, yeah, that'll work.
Root force it, Leon.
Set forth evidence of kith and kin.
Kith and kin?
I don't want to kith my kin.
I kith...
Oh, what's this?
The ring Ada gave me.
when did she give you yeah when did she give you a ring um on our wedding day no wow the kiss the kiss bingo thanks for the gift this door looks awfully modern oh survive the zombie attack oh oh no we should crank it yeah let's crank it let's crank it oh my gosh oh my gosh i'm going i'm going space okay okay oh my gosh wait i'm not try him you got him you got him did i oh it's hard wait keep cranking it ah
wait it might be easier for you it's like on controller yeah okay okay unless it's time like this yeah you can try try try try okay oh my god oh god they're coming from the god oh my god yeah Nope, nope.
I'm coming from that direction anymore.
Oops.
Oh, my gosh, I'm right!
Someone exploded, but I think actually that was okay.
There's some goo happening.
I don't know if they're even coming from that side anymore.
I don't know if they're coming at all anymore.
Wait, wait, wait.
Are you here burning?
Oh, yeah, they're coming.
They're coming.
Nice, nice, nice.
He got him.
Unlimited power!
Keep cranking it!
Oh!
Interesting.
Once again, you just gotta respect, like, the architects who made this giant bronze lion that spews flames forward.
But also, like, what hindsight do you need to feel that you should make this?
Yes!
Yeah, it worked!
We did it!
We survived the zombie attack.
Wait, did they... Oh, they left a lot of loot, though.
Come on.
Hey!
My inventory is so very full.
Me too!
Die, zombie!
Don't give me that!
Just gotta make sure.
Yeah, yeah, of course.
Okay.
We go through?
open oh oh oh i thought some oh okay hi
oh water no oh is it gonna be a drowning level oh gosh you're like an amnesia have you ever played amnesia i have not but i know what you mean the water monster yeah you should play it it's a classic it really is but they're scary Oh, but it's so good.
Just once I like to find a place where it would warm water, you know?
I have trauma from like Kingdom Hearts of water levels.
Oh, I've never played Kingdom Hearts.
Really?
I think you like it.
I just can't get over these anime characters.
And then suddenly Mickey Mouse shows up.
That's the best part!
Just go onward?
There's a fish somewhere.
Yeah, that guy's around.
What are the water levels in Kingdom Hearts?
It's a little mermaid.
Of course, of course.
Of course the little mermaid would be there.
Of course.
Uh-oh, I think we're...
Is Sebastian there too?
Leon.
Yeah, he's there.
He sings and, you know...
Where'd you go?
Hurry it up.
I love us.
This way.
Wait.
If you do it for long enough, does Leon start shouting too?
I guess so.
Maybe.
It's this thing right here.
Oh, this?
Try it.
Hey.
Over here.
Helena!
Yes!
Oh, my gosh.
It's so impatient.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I'm taking the high road.
You always do.
Oh, am I gonna have to fight the fish down here?
No, they wouldn't make you do that alone.
Ooh.
Oh my gosh.
I hear a zombie like freaking out in my ear.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh my god, he was crawling at me while I'm crawling.
That was so scary.
Ah!
zombies in the water no I was safe that's icky it is icky what the I didn't even touch anything can I go swimming in the ocean and think about like all of the the stuff in there I tried not to think about it
yeah that's why though I don't swim in lakes and stuff yeah get that brain I used to as a kid swim in lakes a lot and I would always be terrified of like the seaweed.
The sea?
Oh, there you are.
Hey, where are you?
Oh, hi.
Right here.
I think I gotta crank it.
I'm glad you're here.
Thanks.
Keep turning.
It's working.
I'm going!
Oh!
Oh, I'm getting taken away.
what is that that's the fish i think the fish is eating the zombies though he's hungry the chico system oh did i
shoot you um i don't think you can okay oh thanks i think i gotta go up here there we go yeah oh he won't just crawl under the rope you're going you're going oh you're opening it for me i am my lady go my lady leon i can't get through
did you ever play mario party four four i don't know wait was it four do you remember there's one called like dungeon duos a mini game where you have it's like this and have to like go and open gates might have been mario party three oh yeah i'm good oh my god what is this there's zombies coming behind me i've got saws i have spikes how do i just run through oh my gosh yeah what is powering i know who builds this oh look What twisted mind?
A snake!
A snake just attacked me!
Oh, I see him cranking it over there!
Oh, you do?
Yeah!
Kill him!
Everything here is activated by cranks.
What?
So we kill whoever's during this.
Goodbye, Spears.
Oh my gosh.
I hear a guy.
Well, that guy's got a lot of dynamite.
You killed him!
Thank you.
Oh!
Oh.
Oops.
Give me more money.
Oh, I need, I need a crank.
I got no crank to crank.
Uh, I'm looking for cranks.
I've got a crank.
I'm cranking it.
Oh, geez.
Oh, whoa!
Somebody's...
Somebody's cranking.
Me!
It's me!
You!
Is it working?
How?
I don't know what I'm cranking.
You're doing the spikes.
But they're going faster.
Oh, am I supposed to stop?
Crank's over here.
Oh.
Wait.
No, it was good.
It was good.
Oh, what?
Don't crank it anymore.
Okay, okay, okay.
Where do I go?
Oh, both are closed.
Do I need to find it?
Oh gosh, they're all dying to the saws.
I could hear them just be like...
They're like crawling through.
Am I supposed to go up here?
Oh, yeah, I am.
Okay, I thought so, but I didn't get a prompt at first.
Oh, goodness.
Look at that good...
Oh!
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm okay.
Oh my gosh!
I don't think I'm hitting him at all.
Oh, there he is.
Wait, I have a sniper.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, I needed to reload.
Wait, did I die?
No, no, no, I'm alive.
Somehow.
I got one guy.
Oh, I needed to crank it, I'm so sorry!
No!
Ah!
Help me!
I've died.
You did?
Wait, maybe.
No!
I think I'm dying.
I killed him.
Wait, can I live?
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know how to get over to you.
I'm protecting you.
They're like throwing poo at you.
Oh, I can get up.
Yay!
So maybe I need to do something.
It shows that I need to get over there, but I don't know how.
Oh, I just don't want to go through the...
Through the saws again.
I think you're down!
I think you got...
I'm down!
You got hit by the...
They flung something at you.
They threw a rock at me?
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
Oh, he spit on me?
Where was the checkpoint?
Guess what?
There's no crank here.
I'm going to look for it.
Oh, I need to look for the crank.
There's no guarantee it's even in here.
True.
It was me.
No, I think because there was...
Oh, goodness.
There was...
I saw it on the other side of the thing from you, though.
Oh, wait, did he give me something?
Yeah, no, I can't.
All right.
More cranking.
Got you.
I'll protect you.
Just be careful of the spikes.
Wait.
Oh, I think I need to...
Do I need to go back?
Ow, stop spinning.
I hate them.
If you get far enough, well, I guess...
I wonder if I can take them down from here.
I'll try to check over there.
Maybe.
Oh, I forgot.
I needed to reload again.
Did that take care of them?
Reunite with your partner.
Oh, reunite.
Wait, is it open?
What am I there?
Wait,
but it's a trap beneath the skull.
Oh, watch out, watch out.
If you go to the spikes, I'll crank it.
I'll crank it!
Oh, it doesn't spike.
Okay, yeah, go past.
Go past.
Okay, there we go.
Thank you.
Thank
you.
They're really just flinging these rocks at you, though.
It's like monkeys throwing poo.
I know.
My mom had a monkey when she was a kid.
And it would throw poo at her.
A monkey?
Yeah.
A pet monkey?
Yeah, yeah.
My grandpa brought it home one day.
what can you have one of those i don't know what kind i don't know like a chimpanzee i think probably one of them small monkeys yeah how are you supposed to oh i think oh no nimi i think you have to slide under the blade i know i'm scared ow oh this guy is bullying me i can't reach i can't see him or else i'd shoot him i'm trying to get him he's like armored oh wait i see him he's spitting at me let me try let me try get him again he's got infinite hp oh i'm i'm missing that would have helped he can't be killed i don't think he can't try a grenade good idea wait how do i do that oh wait i can try a grenade too
oh good job okay you oh wait oh how am i supposed to get it is it under the blades wait how do i equip it wait okay no no no no back back oh my gosh you guys i'm so stupid with this is the shift while scrolling it is thank you okay oh i got it i almost just threw the grenade at you Oh,
no.
Thank you for not.
I was real close.
Okay, I got the crank.
Okay.
I just make it through the saws.
I believe in you.
Oh, gosh.
Yeah.
Okay.
I just crawl very slowly.
Uh-huh.
Wait, did you?
I won't stand up.
Wait, did you crank it?
I'm about to- No!
No, no, no!
Zombie?
No, no!
Please, I just got the crank!
Oh, was it a zombie?
Oh my gosh.
Yes, I might live, though.
Wait, okay, I think I need to cover for you then.
No, I think it was just one.
Eat the herb.
I'm struggling over here.
I know, I can tell.
Yay!
Okay, okay, good, good.
Wait, what side am I on?
I'm on the right side!
Oh my gosh!
Our troubles are over.
They are?
I'm cranking it.
Yes!
Your gate is open!
Yippee!
Thank you!
I think we're here together.
Now I crank it.
Watch out!
Watch out?
Oh, was there a guy behind me?
Got you.
Thank you.
Hi, stranger.
Oh, I'm going to take your loot, though.
Oh, yeah.
Come on.
Let's keep moving.
You should.
Sick these kind of things.
Oh, I can take that.
Cool.
Nice.
Finally.
Heleta!
Uh-oh.
It was a trap!
That was something.
We got bad boozled.
Ooh, invented this.
I know, right?
The Caesar?
Beware the odds of March.
Welcome to the center of the earth.
Oh, it is like Indiana Jones.
Indiana Jones but with zombies yeah oh my gosh it's crazy in here oh they've got like axes it is like skyrim oh oh nice wait twofer twofer come
on this is crazy it is oh oh i hear him but i don't see him you hear Oh, you're sniping them good.
I know, I'm almost out of ammo.
This is the only gun I like.
Oh, they're right behind you.
Oh, they can jump.
Why do you have armor?
Oh, nice.
I didn't go back to conserving ammo.
Oh, no!
They are so strong now.
This medieval armor should not be this powerful.
I know.
Elder Scrolls moment Yeah He's crying underground caves Who built this?
Why did they build it with no bridges?
Here's a bridge?
We're not going to let Simmons get away with all this Good I won't rest until he's paid for what he did to Deborah We had Debbie That was her name Yeah, Deb Oh, our sister Deborah You're a skinny guy Ah!
Oh my gosh Oh my gosh They really are just...
They got the armor.
I know.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
You're moving!
They don't give up.
I'm trying to...
They don't.
Why can't I pick up this?
Come on, please.
Let me pick it up.
I think so.
I'm gonna start using...
Oh no!
It's this guy!
Oh no.
I'm gonna use a grenade!
It worked!
New grenade power.
Now I can pick up the ammo.
Oh my gosh!
I'm gonna use a grenade!
I don't think it hurts us, so I think we're okay.
Okay.
Do we just... Oh, I'm gonna use a grenade!
Oh no.
No I'm not.
Hey!
Oh shoot!
God!
Oh my god!
I didn't punch you hard enough.
I think... Oh, I was gonna...
What?
What is it to take the meds?
For me, it's the bumper.
Bumper.
I don't know what it is for you.
I'm sorry.
It's one, I think.
Welcome to the center of the earth.
I think I was onto something, though.
I know, right?
It's kind of awful.
Like a MOBA.
MOBA controls.
I'm onto something, though, with the...
With the...
Grenade though.
Yeah, yeah.
Grenades are the way.
Oh, that guy.
They just started coming out of...
Start coming out of nowhere all of a sudden.
I know.
Somebody up there?
Yep.
Ugly.
Super ugly.
More, more!
They don't stop coming!
They don't stop coming.
I think we could just... I think we just got to go for it.
Maybe they'll just keep coming.
We could run.
Yeah, isn't that like part of Resident Evil is sometimes you don't have to kill all the guys?
That's true.
You just run for it.
Yeah.
If you crank it, I'll cover you.
I promise you.
We're not gonna let Simmons get away with all this.
He is pretty fast.
Oh my gosh.
I said I would cover you, but I got...
We run?
Yeah, let's run.
Okay.
Oh, it's...
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
The guy that screams.
Where?
He was...
It's close.
I'm going.
I'm running.
Okay, I'll run after you.
Oh, they're all behind you.
I know!
Oh my god!
Okay, okay, I'm following you.
I think this is the guy that cries.
Oh my god.
Oh no!
Yeah!
Do you keep running?
Uh, baby!
Wait, I don't remember which way.
This way, this way.
Oh, I'm out.
Oh gosh.
Oh yeah, he's scared.
He's crybaby.
Maybe we could just follow him.
Ah!
Oh!
I got you!
That was so...
Uh-oh.
I got grenades.
Be careful.
We're going down.
Guy does have armor.
I'm going to shoot him in the butt.
Yeah.
Get him in the butt.
They don't stop coming.
Can I drop my ammo that I don't want?
I think you can actually.
You can.
Yeah.
Nice.
Wait, he left a big...
There's a treasure!
Yeah, he left a...
No!
That's so evil!
Are you evil?
We can't?
We can't get it!
They're still coming, though.
I think we just gotta keep going.
There will be more treasure.
Yeah.
I was so lame.
I know.
Oh!
He's gonna scream, though.
He's gonna scream.
I'm gonna scream.
Oh, but he'll give us treasure.
Oh.
Where are we going?
I'm going.
Wait, there's a big guy.
There's a big guy over there.
Oh, there's
so many guys.
All of a sudden.
Use a grenade.
Oh my gosh.
Whoa!
Big guy here.
Just run.
Oh.
Oh!
Is it the baby?
Oh, it's the baby!
It's the baby!
Once you're here, it's okay.
Oh.
Come on.
Can we take him down?
Take his...
Ah!
No pressure?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, maybe we should.
Oh my gosh, why do I always need to reload?
I almost died!
I don't know if we're but...
But...
Could have been anything.
Oh yeah, give us the big...
Oh, that's not even that much.
Some of the other guys are worth way more.
Yeah.
Anything?
Okay, now I think we can keep...
Wait, which...
Which is...
Oh, there's another big guy over there.
Oh, he's got a bomb!
Oh my god!
He was strapped with TNT!
Oh no!
Oh, wait, I aggroed the big guy?
Oh, nice.
Wait, that might be good though.
Where is he?
He's all the way down there.
Oh!
Nice.
Teamwork.
Oh, he's coming.
He's coming.
Oh, oh, oh, he's coming.
Oh, Lord, he's coming.
Oh, wait, I need to reload.
Oh, he's coming.
Oh, God.
Oh, Lord.
Oh, God, he's out.
Nice.
Yeah, we got him.
You got him.
Nice.
No, you got him.
Don't forget his money.
Rob him of all he's worth.
I like bullying them and just kind of like punching them over.
Yeah!
Where do we go though?
I actually, I can't...
There's like an arrow, but how do we...
Do we... Oh!
Wait, how'd you get over there?
Wait, how'd you get up there?
save the whole time.
Uh-oh.
He's got a sparkler.
Sparkler?
Oh, he dropped it.
Why are there so many zombies down here?
I know.
Nice.
Who wants to be buried in the catacombs where once you're buried there, you come back to life as a zombie?
Oh, it's one of those times.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, here I go.
Watch out!
Whoa!
Oh, no!
Leo!
Did I kill you?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Can I throw a grenade?
Will you die?
Try it, try it!
I need your help!
Ah!
Oh, I'm on fire.
Oh, yes, it did.
Oh, yeah, yeah, it really hurt me.
Yeah, yeah, it really hurt me.
I was flailing like a little cockroach.
No.
Wait, wait.
I think I threw you to your doom.
Thanks a lot, Leon.
Uh-oh, there's a big guy.
Oh, there's a couple guys here.
These guys never go down easy.
Uh-oh.
Wait, how can I help you?
I don't know.
I'm gonna snipe him.
That's what I'm doing.
Keeping my distance?
I don't want to corner myself, though.
Where is he?
I don't know where to aim for this guy, Tommy.
I know!
Oh!
Is he down?
Yeah, he's down!
I keep on coming though.
Ah!
Okay.
I'm coming back to you!
I promise I'll make it!
Wait, can you see me?
I believe in you, yes.
Oh, okay.
Can you hear me?
Oh, is that guy?
That's the guy that's transforming.
forming push out oh shoot like i wish i could shoot oh i should i should heal oh you got you're killing them oh shoot oh my gosh everybody's got dynamite over here
oh oh i get everything i see you i almost missed you
Little up.
What's happening with my vision?
Is that happening to you too?
Yeah, me too.
Okay.
The inverted collars or something?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna crank it!
And you'll come to me!
Oh, watch out!
Oh, watch out?
This guy behind you!
I'm trying to get him, but I have to reload!
Someone really thought this was true.
Oh!
Wow, he blew up!
Oh, gosh.
Oh, no!
Uh-oh.
Oh gosh, I'm down.
I'll try to cover you.
Thank you.
Woo-wee.
Who knew the bomb?
I really do.
Oh, it's the world's slowest bridge.
Please.
Oh, there's somebody behind you.
Oh gosh, he's an exploding guy, I think.
Are we like...
changing because oh no he changed oh gosh uh shotgun okay yeah baby kick him while he's down kick him while he's down nice okay good job team oh elena elena come on lena push this boulder with me one moment i'm stealing your loot oh yeah yeah oh wait i can't go ahead Oh,
there's a guy coming at you!
Over here.
Where?
Oh, shoot!
I got it!
Oh.
Ouch, man.
These guys are brutal.
Okay.
Leon.
Leon!
Oh,
he explodes.
Or he transforms.
Why do you have to transform?
Oh, nice one.
I think Leon needs to apologize.
No, I didn't get the points.
It's okay.
I forgot.
Leon needs to apologize for throwing you off a cliff.
Then throwing a grenade at you.
I don't think he's very sorry.
But he's supposed to be sweet baby girl, right?
Right?
Yeah, we were talking about that.
Right before stream.
Oh!
What happened?
Oh my gosh.
I fell!
I tripped.
I fell.
Thank you.
Need a hand.
I'm just so baby girl that I fell over.
It slipped.
Yeah.
We were talking about that, how, like, people portray Leon as, like, they're like, give him cat ears.
It's just a little...
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh.
I go on this side.
Uh-oh.
They're coming.
Ow.
hitting yeah he's got no head in anymore though yeah no spit's gonna be coming out of there ow
all the loot is over there what's the point oh leon this way leon leon i know we i haven't seen him be so baby girl yet though what is the skills whoa people like seeing him as a Is he?
So far he's just like a blank slate.
Yeah.
He's like, oh my gosh, this is so slow.
Oops, it's like how people like, you know, you can hurt your hand playing Mario Party.
Oh yeah.
You're like, don't use the palm of your hand to spin.
Uh oh.
It sounds like we need to run.
Run, Leon.
Everything's falling apart.
Oh my God.
Are you okay?
I'm right behind you.
him oh no there's a lot of guys over here i'm gonna grenade i'm running just run oh
my gosh
thank you ouch i'm on fire i'm on fire there's a boulder oh She keeps falling over.
Indiana Jones!
I guess it would be hard to stand.
Oh, what do we do here?
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
They are so strong.
I know.
Oh, the loot is getting fresh.
Oh, no, not the water.
Is the boulder gonna chase us?
Oh, the water!
We're getting Titanic instead!
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Chris Redfield fought a boulder?
She's another...
What do we do?
Resident Evil?
I think so, yeah.
Right?
Is he from the first one?
Or the second one?
Or the third one?
Or the fourth one?
He's part of this one, the sixth one.
Oh!
He said, said, wait, I remember him in seven.
Performing stroke.
He's at the end.
We're from having a stroke.
Perform stroke.
Where do we go?
Oh, I don't know.
Do we here?
Oh gosh, our oxygen.
Down here?
Uh oh.
Up, up, up.
Perform stroke.
First cranking it, now perform stroke.
I know.
What's this game?
Oh, I think I see zombies.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
The fish?
Yeah.
I think the fish is a friend.
He eats them.
Oh, that's you.
Oh gosh.
Not a zombie.
Oh, they're here?
Maybe?
Yeah, yeah, I think so.
Yeah, the fish eats the zombies.
He thinks they're a tasty little treat.
Watch out for zombies.
Oh gosh.
Oh, I could taste...
I don't know.
Oh!
They can grab.
They can?
Oh, I can grab.
I can help you.
Oh, space.
Oh, never mind.
Sorry, I left you.
That's okay.
Get your air.
Oh.
Oh, ew.
Ew.
Yeah, it's a pretty, it's a pretty icky sight.
Wait, but I don't know if I'm going the right direction.
I'll wait for you.
I think so.
Okay.
Oh, he's grabbing me.
Oh.
Can I help you?
Nah, it's okay.
He just choked me a little bit underwater.
Oh my god, I'm getting choked out again.
Oh no.
Do you need help?
It's like the least optimal place to, you know.
I actually don't know.
Okay, I see you.
I see you.
I'm following you.
All good things.
Follow Nimi Nightmare and you'll see all good things.
Oh, where are you going?
Wait, did you just go inside?
I don't know.
Wait, we just...
No, no, I'm not swimming.
Oh, I'm kidding.
K-Pers are good swimmers.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
Is that air?
Oh, I don't know.
It's a great.
Good thing we're, like, super strong.
I know.
Holy hell.
Did he have AirPods in?
Not my lucky day.
You see that?
Yeah.
He's actually live streaming this whole thing it's like oh the fish came back for you oh my gosh oh my gosh is this a boss i think so mutated fish yeah oh we're not we're oh our flesh is just so young and not rotten fresh yeah oh my gosh oh my gosh i get to watch you do your qte yeah oh dang ew is that his top oh oh i'm mashing mash mash and mash it qte battle i love qte battle it's so slow actually like because you do it for a long long time and then okay now oh no are you no at least oh shoot shoot shoot i was slacking oh no i got it i got it oh for you oh the boogies
okay take a breath oh my god like a dolphin so majestic oh wait how'd you get up there meet your partner on the other side that thing's How did you get up there?
I think he flung me.
I'm gonna pause for one second.
I'm actually gonna move us down a little bit, I feel like.
I'm gonna make us just little tiny heads.
Just so that everybody can see it better.
I'm swimming.
You're swimming.
You take your swimming lessons?
Yeah.
Oh wait, I thought...
Elena.
Do you do something about these bars?
I can try.
Hold on.
I need you to crank it.
Crank it.
I thought I saw a vase.
Dang it.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
I did see one.
Oh.
I'm just getting my cardio in.
You thought.
Little sigil is trying to be so sneaky.
Hmm.
Hiding away from me.
Where are you anyway?
Oh, there you are.
i'm just swimming you are you're really fast cardio i'm hoping to go to the olympics i think i believe in you actually genuinely i this it's really quite far but i'm almost there oh there you are all
right i'm getting my cardio in too i'm going in for track and field
okay did you do any sports as a kid yeah i actually did do track i did too i did cross country oh yeah it wasn't called cross country but it was still like long distance yeah oh wait were you good i was really bad i was actually pretty dang good really yeah i think i missed the crank wait hold on i gotta go back no problem because i just experienced something and it was just like hey you need your partner for this partners women laps um I'm running I didn't see it I was really bad at cross country but I did it out of pure stubbornness because the first day the coach was like 90% of you will quit because you don't have what it takes I was like well I'm gonna I'm gonna have what it takes but i was really bad and i if i didn't get last i was happy i was just to not be the last person yeah i i don't see wait that totally looks like you use your your vision your plot progression vision oh how do you use that again i don't know mine is left bumper
Yeah, I don't know how to get you down.
We're over here.
It shows me...
Am I supposed to do something?
Maybe I was supposed to do something.
I gotta use a laser.
Oh, on the mirror.
I see it.
It's one of those.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Fish.
No.
Um, no.
I mean, yes.
Yes, fish, yes!
Ah!
Oh, what the hell?
I've been swimming so slow now!
It was so good a minute ago!
I shot him.
Thanks.
Oh.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
You're my hero.
Oh.
I need some backup!
Again!
He's needy.
I'm needy.
Oh my gosh, hold on.
I'm reloading.
Ah!
You're fine.
I'm reloading.
calmly he says it he's like dang it oh my god no it never ends oh we're fine everything's a okay just be be over by those torches okay wherever it tells you to go i don't know actually oh my gosh i'm finally out of the water the shark is so slow
Hurry it up.
Hurry it up!
Sure,
but we couldn't push over a rusted- I know.
This thing is amazing.
Oh god.
We're getting slow-mo?
Whoa!
Oh, there's- it's also- can I not reload?
I'm reloaded.
Is that the boss?
I think so.
Debra had.
Did she transform into a shard?
Yeah, maybe she did.
Here it comes.
Oh, ow.
The cuties.
Cuties.
He even warned us this time.
Thanks, Leon.
Oh, my laser.
Oh, my God.
Are we okay?
I don't know, actually.
Even a little close for comfort.
I just shot it as soon as he said something.
Me too.
Sometimes you catch on fire.
Sometimes you don't.
It's just a little bit of a lottery.
It's a spice of life.
Oh yeah.
Quite spicy.
Oh, it is Titanic now.
Oh, Leon.
Oh.
I forgot we were in the 21st century.
That was literally my thought.
God, we have jets?
Whoa.
We're in like the Middle Ages.
I know.
Not the nuke.
Oh my gosh.
He's sterilizing the area.
Oh, that's one way to call it.
This stream is quiet.
Thank God you're still alive.
Where's Simmons?
After speaking with you, he lied.
in a hurry shit where did he go as he was leaving he was talking to someone on the phone he didn't sound too happy well why didn't you take him down why he was right there i've got a tail on him he's on his way you have a pen just like private jet is preparing to leave for china what's in china oh yes take a look at these oh
what is that explosion fire Fire in China.
Uh-oh.
The BSA confirmed it was the same one used in Eastern Europe.
Six months ago called the sea virus.
Is it the same one here?
We saw cocoons just like that here.
Yeah, we did see the cocoon virus.
Cocoon virus.
Is it gonna turn everyone into a beautiful lady like...
Ada?
Keep the project going!
Don't stop the project!
Listen, Hunnigan.
I need you to take our data.
Do you think they have radiation?
What do you mean?
From the bomb.
Oh!
We probably do too, right?
Yeah, that's what I mean.
If you hold your thumb up to it, if it's bigger than your thumb, it means you're dead, right?
Really?
Is that the case?
That's what I learned from the Fallout TV show.
If you hold your thumb up to the mushroom cloud, if the mushroom cloud's bigger than your thumb, it means you're done for.
I got a dog tag.
Look at you, A-Rank always.
Your four deaths.
Most of them went to the sauce.
I know.
I think three of them were, no.
You got a lot more medals than me, though, I think.
I'm not even on these metals.
I don't even know what they are.
Me neither.
Oh, killed an enemy with a grenade.
I definitely did that.
My accuracy is way down.
Because I started using guns.
Yeah, the knife was not quite optimal here.
I'm going back to the knife.
I'm going back.
Stick with what you're...
Uh-oh.
I've got money.
Wait, do communication error.
There's a dog tag.
Oh, no, are we...
kicked out i'm still in the shop though me too okay um let's see what happens what do i maybe i'll get defense level two i just bought melee level two let's go melee holy 80 000 i know wait you're gone i mean i'm gone yeah for my screen are you gone for me?
Or am I going for you?
Oh, wait, yeah.
You're gone.
It's not Steam Day.
No?
Oh.
Well, okay.
I'm in the cutscene.
Are you in a cutscene?
No!
I'm in the shop.
Go to the cutscene.
Okay, okay.
Let's figure it out.
Let's reconvene after the cutscene.
I wonder what's happening.
Oh, it's Thursday.
It's not day this is we're in china wow yeah are we on our own private jets i don't think so who are these people we just under chinese airspace this is a nice plane i know big seats yeah people are just wandering around like in a in a storm is up why don't you turn me in
You know, the seats look big, but maybe it's just that we're very small.
Remember in the dining room?
Uh-oh.
We will.
Are they infected?
Oh, no!
They're infected.
Oh!
Oh my god, he cocooned on the plane!
No.
We're not in the same game, right?
I'm still in the cutscene.
Don't suppose I think it was that plane, do you?
It won't let me pause.
That's okay.
I think I'm about to get... Okay.
I will, um, end game session.
Okay, okay.
I wonder if it's my side.
because I was hosting the collab and then also but I'm still streaming even the internet just glitched for a second maybe I'll do the collab again wait but it still says I'm in oh maybe it's me no no never mind it didn't say host anymore okay okay I quit the game yes okay good yeah me too oh
a ton of online games are down apparently really oh but it says you just joined on my wait did you yeah i think it's loading i did join gotta load all my polygons yeah you're big but you're actually what you're like five foot two mm-hmm you're tinier right uh i don't know you don't know is it a secret oh look at everybody full-body nimi on the screen hi there oh yeah everybody yeah okay all right let me strike a pose oh oh
there you are yay my god wait if i move do you move or am i Am I moving on yours?
I, you are not moving on mine.
You can move me and you however you wish.
Well, how was I moving then?
What just happened?
Sometimes everything's such a mystery, you guys.
Sorry for the hiccup.
Oh, don't worry about it.
They love the scuff.
Don't you, don't you love the scuff?
Yeah, don't, yeah.
Yes.
Admit it.
Oh.
she's not threatening she's she's i'm i'm cute yeah okay i host the game again okay let's go off i hope what if we have i don't i think it's saved right because i know i hope my my shop upgrades went through oh yeah that's true
okay inside the airplane yay okay we get to yeah i'm not sure okay start game and i invite you let me in nimi nightmare non-stop nimi nightmare that's right i was watching oh no i failed to join uh oh can you invite me again oh yeah yeah i was watching your um What's it called?
Your Wii Fit stream.
Oh, yeah.
The yoga.
That was crazy.
Yoga?
I love the Wii Fit yoga.
I love the Wii Fit.
I love anything with Wii Motion Control.
Yeah!
It's so fun to watch it.
If we ever end up in a space together and doing 3D together, watch out because I'm gonna make you play something with me she's gonna make me downward dog you guys him that'd be so fun I know I know have you ever thought about doing VR chat oh I would I could have cleared your name maybe but we have to watch the cut I haven't stopped Simmons yeah besides you're starting to grow me I've played VR chat.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Should we VR?
Yes.
That's true.
I haven't thought about streaming it.
Oh yeah.
There's all kinds of worlds, right?
Yeah.
You can go to anything.
But it can be a little tough like managing camera angles and everything like that.
Oh yeah.
You should stream it, and I'll just be there.
Okay.
Poinsome.
Sorry, we'll handle it for you.
Okay, let's blow this popsicle.
Oh, I just...
I just...
Oh, my gosh.
Sorry.
Are you dead?
Yeah, I just clicked out of the game on accident.
Oh, I have no bullets.
Oh, my gosh.
How embarrassing.
I really want to use my knife, but I feel like that's a bad...
Yeah.
Ah!
Oh, I have like no ammo.
I have my hand!
Oh my gosh, I got you!
Oh my gosh.
I don't have you.
You're fine.
You need a knife then.
Ew, ew, ew.
Picking him.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, flank.
Yeah, just take him down like that.
Oh, I'm reloading.
No, no, that was the perfect time.
No!
I'm sea dodging.
I'm not dodging.
Oh!
I'm sea dodging to the wrong way.
oh he's like he's tooting oh there we go he is did you see that i think we need to um maybe i'm gonna pilot the yeah i'm gonna pilot it helena do you read me can't we put it on auto get to the tail of the plane find out what's wrong okay uh i think what's wrong is there's no one piloting this plane oh my gosh there's so many people on here yeah you guys like help can you guys like do something do something anything anybody oh wait i went the wrong way oh my gosh so sorry i'm going are you okay mister this plane is huge there's like snacks and stuff i know get your seeds and stay there that's that's oh i found it you did wait i'm cranking it okay i'm coming Sorry,
oh my gosh, I almost landed in that guy's lap.
Oh no, wait, are we okay?
Oh no, it says you're gone?
It just...
Yeah, it says you left the game.
Oh wait, I heard it again!
Oh no!
I don't know where you are anymore!
Oh, Leon, Leon, Leon without a person to guide him.
Wait, what's going on, I wonder?
I don't know.
Is this Steam?
Is it us?
Let me steam.
I'll quit the game again.
Network down.
Is steam down?
Is steam?
Maybe.
No.
I feel like every time I Google, like, any website, like, is any website down?
It's always, like, yes.
I don't.
Even if it's not, you know?
I'm going to check Twitter.
steam and you're gone for me again too I know oh wait down detector two hours ago are you having problems with steam you're not alone people have been having problems since 8 27 p.m.
GMT what oh my god I feel like they could tweet that like literally every single day though it would be true right somebody is having problems on any given day yeah um i'm not sure what do we do i don't know uh
steam we took it through a chapter but we did
i can't is any i don't know what to if anyone do you want to try one more time yeah i yeah let's try let's try we can also wait like five minutes and then try that's true yeah wait a little bit restart steam does that help i don't know how to see if anyone else is having issues is the world having issues
maybe maybe steam um
I don't know.
Is Earth down?
Earth is down.
Earth down, detector.
Oh, people are.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
At least we could talk on Discord.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
We're going to have to play the Discord games.
The Discord activities.
Yeah.
Have you ever tried the YouTube games?
No, but I'm seeing them.
I saw you play them.
Yeah.
Actually, some of them are pretty fun.
They're like the mobile games.
and they are but without ads it's actually kind of great because it'll be like you know how in normal games it's like if you want to skip this watch an ad no it just happens yeah oh and they're free they're all free play delta rune on discord i saw that the person who put delta rune on discord is getting in trouble i didn't know delta rune was on discord apparently it it was and they are they have been told to remove it oops i don't think they're getting sued i don't know they posted it on twitter oh like why would you put it
helby fox's legal person just like sent them a nice message honestly considering they stole their game they were just like you need to take this down i've never tried the discord games actually i don't even know how to get to them oh i see like suggested activities yeah we could play um we can play wordle mergeville mergeville
um quiz planet oh this is awkward
wow banana of doom there's actually so much on here i know are any of them good though
oh that sounds fun yeah there's youtube watch together wait there's blocks.io which is just minecraft discord what are you doing with your minecraft knockoff it It looks so similar.
Hmm.
But there, but, but Delta Roon gets in trouble, okay.
Yeah.
Because Microsoft is a forgiving company.
Is it still on here?
It is still on there.
Delta Roon is still on there.
Yeah, if you search for it.
Oh my gosh, you're right.
Delta Roon Chapter 1, Chapter 2.
That's crazy.
you better take it down i'm gonna i'm gonna speed run it so i can play it before yeah before it's gone have you played delta rune mm-hmm have you played undertale yeah yeah i played undertale what about i like delta rune yeah i thought it's good so far it's it's the full thing is out now right or is there no yeah there's still one more part think right i think there's like three more chapters or something oh wow so it's not gonna be done for a long time but it's good what's there is good i will play is it connected to undertale at all or no it's like the same characters but it's like a different universe or something i don't know i don't think people know exactly how it's connected but people have theories that they're very passionate about.
That sounds like the Undertale Delta Room community.
Oh, people are saying they're on chapters 4 out of 7.
Yeah.
It's good, though.
It's good.
I will check it out.
Yeah.
I'll try.
Do you want to try Steam again?
Yeah, we should speaking of trying.
Okay.
Up there.
Continue.
Oh, shoot.
Did I leave?
Oh, wait.
I'm here.
Again.
Oh, wait, you came back.
I'm here.
How did that happen?
You just came back.
I busted in.
Okay, I invite you.
Okay.
Like, you actually just popped out from the bottom of the screen.
Did I?
Oh, hello there.
Hello.
Did it send?
Um, yes.
It might be working.
Oh, okay.
Fingies crossed.
Fingers crossed.
Can I skip this cutscene?
I know.
We can't, we can't skimp it.
Oh, nice, nice.
Okay.
Oh, uh...
Really, I want to knife him.
Yeah, knife!
Who?
I want to see the two.
Just pay attention to his...
This is Benz.
He's shooting at you!
I don't see anything coming out.
It's like blue.
Blue, too.
Yeah.
Did you guys see anything?
Nice.
Blue tube.
There's something wrong with the pressure bulkhead.
Get to the tail of the plane.
Oh, there's a gun here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I picked it up last time.
I missed it last time.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, where is it?
I've got too many guns, though.
Never enough guns.
Wait, where?
Oh, wait.
Do I not have it anymore?
Gun?
I already had it.
I guess it's safe.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
We going?
Yep, we going.
Why are these people just sitting?
I think that's what they all look like Helena tells them to do that.
Oh.
Oh, there's an herb in here.
There is?
Oh, I can't take it.
Dang.
Are there more herbs?
People brought their plants on the plane.
I think that's like not allowed, no?
How does it get through TSA?
One more.
Wait, there is?
That's true.
Oh, but it's both green ones.
Can you combine the greens?
You can.
You can?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, shoot.
Maybe I need to get through.
Okay, let's go downstairs and then I'll combine.
Okay.
Oh, we can wait.
I'm sure the plane's gonna be fine.
Will the collab be fine?
Oh, there's a thingy!
A serpent emblem.
Oh, nice!
There's more plant in here, too.
Oh, yeah!
Wait.
Eat.
What can I throw away?
I don't really use the remote bombs.
Oops.
How do I... Okay.
Discard.
Oh, there's a... There's a treasure, too.
I missed everything last time.
Maybe it's good we started over.
Eye on the prize.
Wait, can I open anything?
Anything else?
Nope.
Did you get the treasure?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Oh.
Are you okay?
I'm fine.
Oh, I don't think we're going back upstairs.
Oh, yeah.
That's a one-way door, huh?
Ow!
Oh!
Why did I do that?
No, I walked right into it.
Oh.
You need my help?
Yep.
Together.
We can push a boulder, but we can't turn this.
Right?
We made it in time.
Oh, good.
Oh, there he is.
Why are these guys in here?
Oh, he is shooting.
Yeah, he is shooting.
Don't get too close.
It smells!
It really does smell.
Open the hatch.
Oh!
Oh my god.
I'm getting my eyes kicked while I'm still.
Ow!
Let me reload!
Are you slowly?
Nice.
Oh!
I'm trying to reload!
Oh my gosh!
It's opening!
I can't move!
Oh!
okay all right ripped to him i think that probably transformed all the people though no oh yeah probably because that was i think the blue gas that transformed the people at the church oh geez that was me oh no
sorry yeah we just dropped him into a bunch of people um he might survive no way i don't think he will but the gas might like explode and yeah it's like fortnite he's dropping to thank the bus driver he would have thanked the bus driver now cool nice he kicked off my bus i was the bus driver i think he smells so yeah he gets stinky
Well, the air should be all nice and fresh now, right?
I can't stop the plane from crashing.
Okay.
Helena, we have to go.
Did they respawn?
I guess so, because I got that one, no?
I didn't do.
Or I thought so.
Yeah, me too.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
No!
They did all turn.
They're all turned.
Oh my god!
I'm just...
They're fresh zombies.
They should be easy to kill.
Yeah.
Hold on.
I'm going to get that.
Holy cow.
The plan is to kill you.
Oh, earlier.
Oh no, you can only have one at a time!
Oh,
oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
turbulence we were too late we were too late oh i got him nice i'm glad there's not like a timer here oxygen masks deployed i know it's so immersive oh my gosh oh my gosh i'm coughing i've always felt that if these oxygen masks were deploying on a plane i would not know how to use them oh i always thought that if they deploy that's it like you're pretty dead i think
it just felt like a fun finale yeah well they always say like the the bag may not deflate or inflate but oxygen is flowing yeah yeah i always feel like there's a lie Like it wouldn't be flowing.
The bag doesn't inflate.
I don't understand how it doesn't inflate them.
I wouldn't trust it.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Ouch, ouch.
Uh-oh.
This is why I can never sleep on planes.
It's a little extreme.
Oh, there's another thing over here.
There's more zombies.
Sorry, I'm just collecting stuff.
That's okay.
There's a serpent emblem over here.
Oh, there is?
Oh, good eye.
What the?
How did you see that?
I feel like I didn't pick up a single one in the last chapter, though.
Uh-oh.
Be-woo.
Jesus Christ, how much worse can this get?
When you open the hatch, you destabilize the plane by letting the pressure yeah i thought about that too leon it's on you nimi my controls nimi is in control my controls okay first switch off the autopilot to restore manual where's the autopilot press the third button in the fourth oh my gosh oh my gosh how do i know what the autopilot is where did all these people come from Oh my god,
it's
a little chaotic, it's fine, we're fine.
I wish I had an eye for it, though.
Pull up, pull up!
Oh, please reload.
Oh my god, we're really pretty low, Nibby, are we okay?
I like this, like, super...
Aida!
She's gonna control the plane with her mind.
Oh,
I think I crashed the plane.
No.
I think you killed, like, 10,000 people.
I think this, um, I think...
They were all zombies?
That was, that was actually, like, a themed airport where it's, you know, they rebuild the buildings every day.
It makes you look like you're crashing into the world.
Or, like, an experience.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
An escape room type of.
Okay.
I know the situation.
Awesome.
Cool.
Oh.
Who is this?
Sherry?
What are you doing here?
Is that Chris?
I heard you became an agent.
Why are you here?
I'm tracking the man behind all this.
Chief Security Advisor Simmons.
What?
There must be some sort of mistake.
I report to Simmons.
He's your supervisor.
we're on our way to meet with him right now it's our chance we're gonna kill your supervisor Jake you're not Chris Jake she looks so pretty she's like flawless right now the world is burning down your orders were to avoid contact with anyone Leon's not just anyone he saved my life back in Recon City she was in the city
leon's be saving lives uh oh um what is that oh my god sherry okay good oh my gosh she's got jake i really thought they were dead we do the slow mo oh my gosh What the heck is that?
This looks like the thing from the movie.
An ex-girlfriend?
Is there Resident Evil?
Yeah, there's a couple Resident Evil movies.
Are they good?
Are they really good?
Actually, I've only seen the first one, I think.
I
want to stab him with my knife.
You think that's a bad idea?
No, no, do it, do it.
Oh, shoot!
He's strong.
Is he?
You're doing a great job distracting him, too.
I just gotta shoot him in his butt when he turns around.
Do I have anything else?
I have this.
Oh.
If I can reload it.
Oh!
Dodge, dodge, dodge!
Dodge!
Watch out!
That didn't quite work.
He's running.
Hey!
Oh!
Dodge!
I tried dodging again and it didn't work.
It's like a bull!
Oh my gosh, it didn't work!
I pressed C so many times!
Oh my gosh, Jake is saving me.
Wait, can I punch you?
Oh, Jake did not do anything to me.
Oh gosh, oh he's got me!
He's got me!
Heal?
Oh, I have no heal.
Wait, I have a spray.
Okay.
I have too many guns.
Where'd he go?
Oh.
Okay.
He must be the final boss of this chapter.
He must be.
Wait, but there's a ladder here.
I want to climb it.
Wait.
Oh, there was stuff to explode.
Oh.
Oh, man.
That would have been cool.
It would have been really good to use.
I mean, we got him, no problem.
He's still, yeah, he ran away with his little tail between his legs.
I'm here, too.
Oh, whoa.
Oh,
shoot.
I thought I was going to cut her throat.
Perfect.
Wait, are you okay?
Yeah, I'm okay.
Punched?
No, I got it.
Are we separated?
Yeah, we're...
I'm fighting him right now!
Oh my gosh.
Why does my dodge not work anymore?
How do I get to you?
Holy cow.
Oh, geez.
I'm...
Maybe I never do how to dodge, did we give with...
Oh my gosh, a person thinks I'm not meaning to!
Can I shoot something?
No, it's okay!
Oh my gosh, wait, if that guy distracts him.
Wait, I'll distract him.
Oh!
Yeah, get over!
Yes, yes, yes!
Go over here.
Come, come, come, come!
Come, come, come, come, come!
Come, come, mister!
Okay, I'm just doing some auto maintenance right now.
Oh, sorry, I'm Jake.
Just casually.
If you're doing maintenance, okay.
Yeah, I'm just working on a car really quick.
Wow!
Are you kidding?
I got a kick out of this.
Wow!
Okay, incoming!
Car, incoming!
She was right on top of the things.
How did I shoot too soon?
Don't get me started, but maybe the four of us can stop him once and for all.
Okay.
I'm gonna stab him.
Oh.
Was that you?
My little knife.
Oh.
That wasn't me.
Okay.
I'm so almost out of bullets, it's actually kind of insane.
Oh no.
I like him actually.
Can I share with you?
I...
away but I don't remember how people said if I drop it on the floor did you get to pick it up maybe I don't know yeah I'm currently looking for box give him credit at least he came prepared where is he is that grenade watch out me too oh never mind I'm not close like I said indestructible I was hoping No,
I'm also low on ammo.
Yeah.
Wait, I could use these remote bombs too.
Come here!
Oh,
okay.
How do I actually activate it?
Oh, okay.
I'm slicing him.
You are?
Okay, I'm coming back with bombs.
My remote bombs.
Ouch.
Okay, everybody might get hit.
So sorry.
Okay, should I leave?
Oh!
Pretty nice!
It worked!
Good one.
I did nothing the entire fight.
You did!
I gave in with white bomb!
Sherry, listen!
Until we get there, I need you to- Oh!
Oh, Sherry.
Are they gonna be alright?
Let's just hope that Jake hits as good as he thinks he is.
Are they fighting?
Are they beefing?
He is jealous.
I have to go to the bathroom.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Yeah.
After the plane went down, I linked in a minute ago, but you weren't picking me up.
Listen, the building Agent Berkin mentioned isn't far off.
Just stick to your current route, okay?
Okay.
Oh, thank goodness there's ammo.
Oh, sweet ammo.
Guys, I'm utilizing the weapons.
We are killing it.
We're killing it.
Nimi, we're doing it.
Sweet, sweet, I'm a...
They delicious.
I'll cover.
Okay, there's a door here.
We don't need to go inside just yet.
I'll wait.
Oh yeah.
Leon, get off your phone!
Leon!
We have so much to do.
Wait, Leon, watch this, watch this.
I can only dodge one way.
I don't know how to dodge.
Even if I hold left.
I can only...
Wait, Leon.
Wait.
Leon, are my boobs in your face?
He looked away!
What a gentleman!
He's playing Uma Musume!
Naplings, this one's for you.
you.
Leon's playing Meow Tower.
It's the best game.
Wait, does the door require two players?
Oh, it does.
Leon.
Hurry it up.
Can you hear it?
This way.
Hello?
Hi.
What are you playing?
Meow Tower?
Do you know Meow Tower?
No.
Is that a, is that a YouTube playable?
No, it's a phone app, but I really like nongrams, like Peacross.
Oh, I love Peacross.
Yeah, you should play Meow Tower that you basically, you do the puzzles, and then you collect cans of tuna, and you spend it on ways to decorate the little cat's rooms.
That sounds like this game I've been playing called SqueeCross.
SqueeCross?
Just like that, but you have a rat.
You saw Picross puzzles to buy furniture and clothes for your wrap.
For the wrap!
Wait, that's so cute!
It's really good!
Wait, what's it called?
Ket?
Meow Tower.
Yeah, I play it every day.
Now I'm gonna play Squid Cross.
Yeah, I recommend it.
It might be my Game of the Year.
Oh, nice!
It's Game of the Year.
It's so good.
Sherry said she was meeting Simmons in the Koon Lung building.
The first thing you're gonna need to do is cut.
to the outdoor market up ahead they're so cute they're so cute they are they're all roosters though oh no because they're fighting them probably you think so they're not gonna fight us i'm gonna let him free let them free let you out let you out okay i'm gonna get you out of here i'm gonna get you out of here you should be in there i'm gonna get you out of there some people say I hate this part.
There's not animal stuff as well.
I hope not.
I'm not good with that kind of stuff.
Me neither.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
This way.
I think we know which way.
Are we just running?
What was that?
Trouble.
Strawberry?
Oh, my God.
Are you okay, mister?
Where did it go?
I don't think he is.
Oh.
great three separate locks okay what are they hiding all right let's just figure out a way to open it oh wow how handy cool oh oh
wiki yes that's why the whole street is unlocked out residents are trying to keep it out what well this one is different it's different all right
Wait.
He was just birthed in front of us.
Yeah.
Well, he can be stabbed.
Yeah, anything can get stabbed.
Wait, I think we gotta...
Oh, no, he's gonna reconnect, no?
Oh.
Do we have to watch the cutscene every time, too?
This isn't working.
How long are we gonna keep doing this?
Should we just avoid him?
Yeah.
Well, I don't use ammo.
Um, I have grenade!
Oh, catch.
Oh, I see where a key is.
Okay.
I'll go try and grab it.
I hate the sound that it makes.
It's like a baby.
Yeah.
Wait, am I in here?
Wait, I think it's dead.
Wait.
Oh, the key is in there.
We need to find the breaker to kill these live wires.
I have proven.
Is it still alive?
I don't know.
It's making sounds, but...
You need to unlock it from the other side.
It seems defeated.
There's so much.
First, we have to find a breaker.
Then we gotta find a way to open that.
Um, okay.
Wait, is this a breaker?
This looks like a breaker.
Oh, yeah, you did it.
I found another door.
That guy's still crying.
He's just crying around over there.
Oh.
Wait, where did you go?
I'm by where the breaker was.
Oh, where the...
Where...
Not the breaker.
Where the things...
I think he's right behind me.
Excuse me.
Okay.
That guy...
Key?
Ooh.
Oh.
Are this fish?
Wait.
Nice.
What's in there?
Nothing.
Ugh.
These guys are freaky looking.
I know!
I don't want to eat that.
Okay, through here.
Is it a monkfish?
Is that what it's called?
Interesting.
Got an ugly one.
Just reach your hand through.
Yeah.
You're a big boy, Leon, Kennedy.
You don't want it from the other side.
Oh, I got it.
I saw it.
Ah!
Oh my god!
Are you okay?
There's a hand on my face.
Sorry, I might have thrown it over there.
Did you really?
You can pick it up and throw it.
You can!
There's the serpent.
Oh, gosh.
It's coming at me.
Over here.
Uh-oh, I missed.
Do you want to get the serpent emblem?
Um, oh, there you are.
I was like, where are you?
There's one over here.
Oh.
He got that guy.
Nice.
Yeah, take him out.
Take him out.
That guy, duh?
Or...
I feel like he always comes back.
Yeah, eventually, right?
He just twitches for a little bit and then...
Emblem.
There's an emblem over here.
I see.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Oh, I keep going.
the yay thank you yay we break these oh wait maybe i feel like we're getting further from the key i know oh there's an herb nice wait i think i can combine them now wait did it combine me too nice the herb combining makes no sense to me but me neither but i i like it okay i think i did it where are we herb oh there's a little hand oh i got you thank you how it it sounds so gross i know oh it's got right there wait there's a thing right here so uh what is this oh no just kidding is it the door yeah i was tricking me it definitely tricked me put the key in though there's a key on this side as well oh checkpoint oh why what happened i put the key in oh okay i see oh how do we get to this other side oh wait is it here oh it's here right yeah i hear something a boss i hear something walking oh my gosh watch out leon i'm sure it's fine oh uh did i get it maybe i'm just slicing them nice yeah just slice and dice baby oh they turned like they turned like Gray,
and then they're no longer a problem.
I can't reach this thing.
Oh, there we go.
Stupid, ugly.
Oh, I'm going to throw it.
Yeah.
Throw it against the wall.
How did you pick it up?
Oh, it attached to him.
Stop.
Oh, oh, oh, ew, ew, it's crawling on me.
I hate it.
Yeah, it's pretty icky.
It is icky.
We got him.
I hate the sound that they make.
I don't like it at all.
That's a huge microwave!
Also, it's in Japanese.
But we're in China.
Fushigi.
Okay, so you got the second key.
Did you just put it in?
Oh.
No, not yet.
I'm just opening this shortcut.
Wait, well, this is...
What did I just flip?
Yeah, this is good.
Oh, we can go up the ladder.
Did you come up here?
No, I didn't.
I didn't notice there was a ladder.
Oh, I can launch you!
Throw me.
No.
No, do a flip.
She's cracked.
She's crazy.
All right.
All right, Helena.
Oh, yeah, maybe the key is over there.
Helena against the world.
Yeah, I'm like right next to it, but I don't know where it is.
Why is there scary music?
You're on your own.
I don't like that.
This time.
Oh, no, I need you.
You need me?
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
I can open this over here.
Come on.
Uh-oh.
And then you come to where the, the, um, what's it called, was.
I keep wanting to say the strawberries.
I mean, they are strawberries.
It's weird.
Isn't it right here?
No.
I'll open this.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, don't run.
Don't.
I'm right here.
Oh, oh.
Nice.
Uh-oh.
Are they all, like, respawning?
Oh.
I think so.
I'm spinning!
Uh oh.
Oh, he's throwing his hands.
Throwing hands.
It's so nasty.
It's so itchy.
Wait, oh, stop it, stop, stop, stop.
Don't, don't, don't, don't, where'd he go?
Stop it, stop.
Stop, stop, stop.
He's just tanking.
Oh, I threw it.
No!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
I think I got him.
Wait, nope.
He's just slithering along.
No!
No more!
Too many hands!
Throw the hand, oh!
That gave a lot of skill points, though.
Ooh, oh yeah!
Oh yeah!
I have one bullet.
That's crazy.
Oh, right here?
Hey, Elena.
I'm coming.
Elena.
Oh.
Oh, golly.
Okay, I'm going to throw a grenade inside.
Okay.
Watch out.
Ooh, nice.
That works.
Oh, okay.
Um.
Oopsie.
Let me just reload and...
BOW!
Nice!
Oh, they really...
They're just wriggling.
I know.
They're nasty.
They drop a lot of stuff, though.
Which is pretty nice.
And a key!
Oh, it's these kinds of toilets!
Ew, they came from the toilet!
Yeah.
I've never had to use one of these.
I've had to just once.
Oh.
Yeah...
I wouldn't even know how.
Oh my god!
You okay?
I'm okay.
It's just a regular old Thursday.
There's another one!
Get him!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, there's a whole ass guy coming out of there now.
Stop!
I always miss the QT.
Ow, ow!
Should we just run?
I'm going to blow them up.
Again.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to run.
Oh, jeez.
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm okay.
I love explosives.
I love exploding things.
I'm here.
I'm a new ghost.
have been reborn but oh really before i didn't explode anything now i know how to explode and i'll explode yeah that's true oh no no no oh oh my god put me in the blades oh don't do it don't do it oh uh uh are you okay oh put me in the blades put me in the blades oh my god
We go together.
That was so romantic.
Would it would have been if he was a little cuter.
I thought it was going to tell me to press V, but it didn't say anything.
Okay.
I missed.
I missed my cutie.
I won't lollygag.
I'll...
Oh, wait.
It's now longer.
Oh, I know it didn't.
Oh, I missed my cutie.
oops it's my pivoting oh no
nice you guys that was an example of what both cutscenes look like for your education yeah yeah exactly I don't like this thing me neither I'm after you my lady okay I won't fail this time maybe can i even help i don't think so i'm mashed oh oh i did it oh my god
nice oh it's coming out of here looks all clear now looks all clear now we don't want to miss simmons okay what he just hey He left nothing behind.
No sausage?
Nothing.
It had a waste.
That was crazy.
That was.
That was pretty cool though.
That was like a hitman assassination.
That was like gruesome.
That was like the most like gruesome, like a...
Ada.
Ada, I mean...
What did you call her?
Ava.
It's quiet.
two what is she suspicious look at her what the hey why are we shooting at her no someone else oh someone else she's like a secret agent why is she so cool let's get some answers wait is there anything down here oh it's locked we'll just find another way through we have to go i'm looking around for loot bullets baby bullets please game please i was was so I feel like last stream I was like oh my gosh the game is so generous with like everything now the difficulty spike has arrived has oh more of this we've got to make it to that elevator run run dash dash dash I'm ready to slide I don't remember what it told me to slide oh we're supposed to slide through I don't think this is I don't think this is her Ow oh no I slid I promise I don't have time for your games What do we do here?
What's up?
I'm kicking it Okay, you don't slide through I think I think I died Did you die?
I might have I got you at first Oh no, I'm fine
nice get inside before the next one we'll take the stairs okay okay i don't like elevators anyway yeah what if we got stuck in there that'd be so bad oh i know i hate this camera this is so re1 oh my gosh wow like the fixed camera the way you're running is so crazy
lot stuff in here oh okay oh nice nice oh first aid yes there is thank you yeah oh wait there we go
nice uh oh yeah that's never a good idea when they give you a lot of stuff oh that's true yeah i guess so i don't know i don't like the look of it me neither And it's only letting me walk so slowly.
Yeah, no, no, no.
I'm ready for the boss fight.
It won't let me change weapons either.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
There we go.
The dramatic slow walking.
It's locked.
Locked.
Where's the boss?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
maybe don't maybe this is aida the the oh the one that came from the egg yeah yeah and so maybe it's not the real aida yeah oh my god what is it what the hell is she thinking i'll ask her once we catch her leon helena come in i don't think this is working i'm trying to get the lock open for keep trying to hack it let's see if you can bypass it manually do these actually blow up they're like yeah they do they're like evil room buzz evil room buzz security breach detected in room one undo the locks of the barriers oh you run interference i'll work with honey again to override oh oh it's r oh okay the cure is breached detected in room one oh okay okay did i do it oh i think you're doing it a breath we can do this okay calm down and try again it's a rhythm game security breach detected in room one okay is this working security breach detected yeah yeah security breach detected in room zero okay security breach detected in room one oh my god security breach detected in room zero okay i did
it security breach detected in oh it's green I think so!
I hacked it.
I hacked the system.
Easy peasy.
Let's go after her.
Oh, nice.
These open, they do.
Get the treasure.
Woo-hoo!
New points.
She was right here.
She was.
More treasure.
Dang.
They were like, good job, team.
Is that the boss?
Are we going here?
Oh, I see him.
In here?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Yelling right in your face.
Oh gosh.
Can I kill her or no?
Ada, no.
Ada, please.
Oh.
Oh, she ninja bombed you.
It's been fun.
She's so cool.
Yeah.
With her little...
She has her own story on here, too, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Your friend likes to play hard to get.
Uh-oh.
Is that the smoke?
Is that...
Oh, my God.
Where do you go?
Okay.
Did he answer himself?
I think so.
Don't lose her.
I won't.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming!
He's mad!
I've got her!
Who's that?
Is that Chris?
When will we meet Chris?
Whoa.
Why should you transform?
Who are these guys?
I don't know.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, it is!
Chris!
Oh, I'm defending her!
Milady!
I won't let them hurt you.
He is in love with her.
I'm gonna...
Yeah.
She's just standing there.
She likes watching men fight over her.
Oh, so dramatic.
Chris?
Leon?
What are you doing here?
Chris!
Put your gun down, Chris.
She's a key witness.
We need her.
A witness?
She's the one who did all this!
No.
It wasn't her.
It was Simmons, the National Security Advisor.
I lost all my men because of her!
And I lost over 70,000 people, including the president, because of Simmons.
Not the president.
Oh, she's working for Neo-Umbrella.
You know what that means?
Yeah.
Not an umbrella.
And you're still going to protect this woman?
Leon, you simp?
I am.
It's true love.
It is.
He will even be evil for her.
Yeah!
Evil Leon arc!
She's so hot and she knows it.
Oh, not the grenade, no!
Oh.
It's so cool.
Freeze!
Damn it!
My ears.
My eyes.
He's gonna kill her.
Chris!
We both want the same thing here.
Ada?
All right.
The BSA will handle Ada.
You take care of Simmons.
Yeah.
Come with us, Chris.
Chris!
I know you'll do the right thing
Are you sure we can rely on him?
He's been in this as long as I have Longer?
No.
I don't know.
I guess so.
If we're talking release date Is Chris the first one?
I don't know, actually.
Chat.
We need the lore.
Yeah.
Leon, Helena, come in.
Technically, yeah.
If Sherry's intel is on the money, Simmons should be just up ahead.
Be careful.
Oh, we're almost to Simmons?
That's so exciting.
Oh.
Now we get, we getting ammo.
Yeah, baby.
I hope you made the right choice, Chris.
What's going on?
What am I looking at?
What are you looking at?
the door and it's all dramatic our target is Simmons always has been you don't regret not following always has been got to your back right now we need to focus on Simmons all right let's go get this son of a bitch yeah all right this feels like the final boss I was about to say is this the end but there's still one more chapter though right I...
I can't remember how many everybody said.
I thought five.
But I don't remember.
Whoa, whoa, cinematic!
Oh yeah!
Cinema, I got to see a pretty...
A whole load of booty.
So what?
I have Helena.
Oh yeah, she's got a nice bond.
That's true.
I like that her tank top is exposing a little bit of her midriff.
He's got, like, the Matrix agents with him.
No, wait.
Ah, Agent Birkin, impeccable timing.
Kindly take these two into custody, won't you?
They said you were involved in the terrorist attack.
Is it true?
What?
Are they running down the street, screaming it to anyone who listens?
It's for the benefit of the United States and global security.
You can't see how killing the president is good for the country.
Oh.
The president's dead?
Well, we had Leon to thank for that.
Where's his zombies?
Dispose of them.
Matrix.
What are you going to do, shield them from the pool?
What is it?
Hold your fire.
Those two are still of use to us.
You need to be more careful.
Yeah.
We shoot them.
You think you can make it to that door?
Why don't we just waste them?
Because I need you to take care of Sherry.
Can we wrap this up?
I do have better things to do.
What are you two gonna do?
Finish Simmons.
Shoot him.
There's information on here that could stop the sea virus.
Well, I'm not gonna give it to him.
Why do you have that?
now move oh nice alert the men outside alert the men wait do we have to deal with men now oh who's that oh they thanked him wait what he's like dissolved wait did they just oh no I got me they gave him the virus oh he's gonna become mega Simmons oh uh-oh the greener goblin he's getting away come on
i don't know this is she was it aida aida i don't know green devil for real
go after derrick shimmons okay okay oh the train fight that's a classic we can't let him escape
I don't know how to use doors Sometimes like the little Prompt doesn't show up exactly How oh no no rush here It's okay, Leon Is there a way To open it fast Some ammo Time to pay for everything you've done Oh please Camera Okay nice Oh and there's some Oh I can't grab the herb Oh I mean let me throw something away we got time right there's no timer on the screen oh but i have so many bombs i don't want to get rid of my bombs
what can i combine there's nothing i just threw away my default ammo oh i might regret it later nah it's fine I know I have no herbs to combine, you guys.
That's okay.
Yeah, we're...
We're fine.
Oh, I am door-wielding my pistols now.
You're too cool.
I wish I could have a knife.
Yeah, how come you don't get a knife?
Yeah.
I'm just giving you exactly what you...
Ooh.
Is that fatal?
But don't worry.
Okay.
Whoever this is is sounding pretty villainous.
We've got you.
She got that evil, sultry boy.
Yeah, yeah.
That woman is on the loose.
What woman?
That traitor, Ada Wong.
Who knows what she's got in store.
Another team was sent after her.
You Simmons?
You're all ours.
to avenge the president is that it you fool just push him off don't let him do his monologue so i always make that mistake or always listening to the monologue so to avoid one possible disaster you create another no matter how many people die he had to be stopped he was leading my country and this world it's a complete this is a chaos it seems pretty chaotic to me How dare she do this to me?
Taste of your own medicine.
We should get him before he gains his ring.
Oh, no, it's a ring!
Oh.
Oh, my God.
He's poking out.
He looks like a character from Metal Gear.
Oh, not so much anymore.
Oh, my God!
Yeah, we should have shot him way earlier.
Oh, my God.
He's the reverse Pokemon evolution.
Wait, oh, V?
Ah!
What did he just say, V for?
Oh, why did I just do that?
So sorry.
I'm going to go salmon.
Yeah, do it, do it.
Hope for the best.
Oh, he's a person again.
Yeah.
Okay, are we running?
Wait, what just happened?
I don't know.
I thought we were going to kill him.
He's a shapeshifter.
Oh my gosh.
I hope you were hurting me, otherwise I just wasted my...
You're just stabbing him!
Take him out!
I'm getting him!
This works!
Ouch, ow, he stepped on me, oh no!
Uh-oh.
You're in.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Yeah?
I'm gonna get him.
I'm just gonna...
Take your time.
Take your time, you know?
Oh!
No!
Did I die?
It's okay.
I think it was a checkpoint.
But I was just on the floor.
I'm gonna grenade.
That's a good idea.
Oh, okay.
Let's get some distance.
We have the chance.
Oh, damn you.
Damn you both.
This again.
Yeah.
Maybe I can play on the flip.
But it was pretty fun.
No.
Nice.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna...
I'll just heal this time.
I'm gonna let him come over to me.
Come on, keep walking, keep walking.
You're right on top of a bomb.
I gotta get him.
Why did I do that?
Okay.
Free ammo?
Oh, I can't hold.
Wait, wait, don't go away.
I just put that there.
He leave?
Yeah, he left.
Oh, free ammo.
Um...
Oh!
Ouch!
He's man-mode!
Oh.
Yeah, the unload item!
I wish he would come closer.
Dang it.
Sorry, I totally missed it.
I totally fumbled that.
No, that's okay.
I fumbled that so hard.
Oh,
here we go.
And...
Oops.
That hurt me a little more.
Oh, wait.
Did I shoot you?
Oh, nice!
No!
Punch in his ass!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Feel my fury.
Oh, okay.
And beep.
And come back up.
Come over here, please, sir.
Never mind.
Oh, he's going up.
No!
I wish I could pick it back up.
I think he, like, comes through maybe on the other side.
Oh, yeah.
Run back through the train.
Yeah, I'm gonna reload.
Oh.
How do we get up top?
I just sprayed myself.
That's fine.
Hello.
I think he's over here.
He's gonna hop through here, I think.
Okay.
Maybe?
I know there's an opening here, no?
Oh, wait.
Oh, he's on the other side.
Oh, I can lift you.
Oh, you can, okay.
Over here!
Okay.
Yeah, because he's just, like, chilling up on the roof.
Oh, he's coming!
Oh,
he's...
I don't know.
I want to stab him.
Wait.
Did he kill him?
Wait, was that it?
He dropped bullets.
He's dead.
He dropped bullets!
Oh!
Oh, Leon!
Oh no.
He's even bigger.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I keep him occupied.
Oh, is that a QTE?
Leon!
I wasn't fast enough.
Okay, I gotta keep him really busy.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'll remember to run this time.
I'll grenade him.
okay that didn't do anything oh shoot oh shoot he's so slow oh my god he's not that slow oh my i'm slow i i don't know how i got over there but whoo slugs oh slow bow oh it's another checkpoint nice okay thank goodness it's happening Yeah, the crazy stressful part.
Maybe your stressful part is coming.
Yeah.
Up next.
It's my turn.
Your turn.
Should I be hitting him?
What are we aiming for?
Oh, wait, there was a thing?
I think.
I don't know.
I thought I...
He's got me!
I'll just...
Oh.
He hurts.
Oh, you can take cover.
Yeah, I think...
Oh.
You can't tell what to aim for.
The brain?
What's the brain?
Their brain?
Is that that part at the top?
You can't tell.
I'm like looking at him.
Oh, maybe even...
Oh.
Oh, take cover!
Just shoot again.
Oh.
Oh, ew, ew.
Oh!
Holy cow.
Oh.
Oh, he's swimming in.
Oh, that's the brain.
It's got a face.
That's the brain.
I always have my hands off the controller with the cursor.
Who's that arrived?
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
He's throwing a minute train.
I can't tell when it's another cutscene and when we're gonna start doing stuff.
like it's so when do we start playing oh my gosh wait oh what happened I think we brought it oh perfect aim
dang he's so cool though I know he should be grateful for this right it turns him into a beast
do something thing you guys there's something keep keep showing
the world will be a better place so cool
right in between the eyes let's go baby That was a good one.
Leave him!
Who's controlling this train?
This
is the most action movie-oriented one.
I know!
Seriously.
Holy moly.
Well, that guy's down.
Wait, so was it?
Ada gonna be the final boss?
Maybe.
But then what about her story?
We just haven't heard her side of the story.
Yeah, sure.
I'm sure she's not evil.
Wow.
I just put it together that this is the game right before Resident Evil 7.
Which is like a crazy jump.
Yes, there is.
It is.
A crazy jump.
I don't know.
But we did what we could.
We got sliced and diced.
Why the trap?
They're so tired.
Can we take a nap?
Uh-oh.
Who's there?
I think there's like military men who will control us.
Maybe they have a spray for us.
Yeah,
well, how long was it between this game and 7?
Because I remember seeing this game a long, long time ago.
And then 7 was...
What?
I don't know anymore.
I don't know.
I feel like it came out not so long ago, but someone's going to be like, it came out 10 years ago and I'm going to be...
Five years?
2012 and 2017?
It's a pretty big gap.
Yeah.
I just said, yeah, at the same time as Lillian.
You're in sync.
Leon, we have a situation.
Sherry and her companion were abducted.
Oh no.
Uh-oh.
abducted and why why he sounds so sad he loves her doesn't he no this is trish no was that was that her name is the key to stopping the sea virus it's on the phone does he love sherry or does he love ada i feel like he loves both why did i say trish i meant sherry i'm really sorry i'm bad with names we do New Resident Evil OC.
Yeah, it just made her up.
Chris Redfield.
Leon, where are you?
Chris, we're just outside of Tachi.
Get the hell out of there!
Uh-oh.
They're gonna blow it up!
Oh!
Oh, they are!
That's so sad.
No!
They said no sea virus here!
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
That's sad.
We did that.
It's just a lot of smoke, though, right?
Oh, wait.
Is it the zombie smoke?
Oh, it might be.
Why are they doing this?
Why are they...
They're purposefully turning everyone into zombies.
No!
But Simmons is dead.
So who gave the order?
Dun, dun, dun.
I'm like,
for anybody.
I don't know.
Maybe I just don't have the political mind.
That's the search.
Watch this.
Oh, there's S-Rank.
I got an S-Rank.
Oh, my gosh.
Whoa.
Wow.
We didn't...
How did we kill hardly any enemies?
I was just...
Yeah, enemies.
Maybe those guys that kept respawning they didn't actually die oh i guess so i guess that was mostly it yeah your accuracy too mine's going lower though it's okay where you're still gaming you don't need accuracy you have the knife oh i can't i can't afford knife level three though i'm gonna upgrade the critical hit level two But now I need to save for everything else.
I know everything's so expensive.
Yeah!
I'm trying to wonder if I don't want Eagle Eye anymore.
Arrow pickup increase?
What increase?
Arrow?
There's a bow and arrow?
Oh, there's a bow and arrow!
Apparently.
I'll just I'll keep it as is I suppose You can't record anything good There's a general item drop increase?
Would that apply to both of us?
Oh, it's on Ada.
I think it's just one.
Okay.
I don't think you've used This is the last chapter, right?
Eagle, I should be automatic, no?
I don't know actually what chapter are we on I think oh we are next one's the next one no way wow oh my gosh we got this okay I'm ready eagle eyes extra zoom oh wait I haven't been I bought this thing and I haven't been using it wait seriously wait how do I get okay wait I'm just gonna buy then we'll buy a firearm I bought firearm too yeah and then Equip.
There we go.
Okay.
Let's go!
I'm ready!
Me too!
Final chapter!
Oh my gosh.
What's gonna happen?
Leon!
So that's Chris.
Yeah, that's Chris.
Oh gosh.
Oh yeah, that's pretty bad.
It's real bad.
it almost sounded like the wilhelm spring that's what i was thinking i was literally thinking that ah i need to get that as a sound board no that'd be so good
it was wait it actually was even they could just cut it cut it a little short it takes me out every time i hear it in a serious context Lord of the Rings.
Wait, where is it in Lord of the Rings?
I used it like three times in the Lord of the Rings.
Why?
It's like such a serious...
Ada Wong is dead!
What?
No, your girl is dead.
No.
Maybe it's...
Maybe she's not.
Maybe it's the fake Ada.
Don't let him down.
Don't cry, Leon.
Don't cry.
Are you okay?
She's so pretty.
I know.
Let's just find the survivors and get the hell out of here.
drivers.
That's optimistic.
Can you read me?
I know.
HQ to Echo.
Hey, what the hell are you guys doing over there?
Oh.
We need to evacuate.
Come on.
Okay.
This guy's gonna...
Who is this cover us?
He's gonna cover us.
Oh.
We're moving in to search for surviving evacuees.
Wait.
Where do they even go?
Don't go there.
We want to help.
Yeah, we want to help.
Oh no, you guys are all doomed, sorry to say.
Oh no, don't breathe the blue.
It's the gap.
It's the...
Oh, wait.
Oh, we're good.
No, don't run that.
Don't run in there.
No!
Don't go near the gas.
I'm sorry.
They are covering us.
Are they really?
Wait, I was just looking around.
Oh.
Holina.
I'm coming.
I'm protecting the people!
Oh, I'm near the gash.
Okay, oh, okay, sorry, sorry.
I'm protecting the people.
Okay.
Ada's dead!
Banners anymore!
The gash looks so pretty, though.
That could be blue raspberry.
Oh, gosh.
Where do we go?
I'm following the guy.
Oh!
Wait, we just...
What just happened to me?
Uh-oh.
Wait, I thought we were immune to the gas!
I thought so too!
Whoa.
What's happening?
Metallic.
What?
That was like...
Yeah, why was I...
Like...
That was like...
Chrome.
Special edition.
What the...
Freezing in the chemicals.
Oh, it's a time...
It's a...
Oh, we're back here.
Okay.
Again, apparently it's a fight against time.
So we just gotta run for it.
Oh, okay.
And I just sat...
Wait, which way?
Wait, I'm going the wrong way, aren't I?
Oh wait, I might have doomed us.
I'm going, I'm going!
This way!
I'm here, I'm here!
Okay, and then I think we go up here, right?
Oh yeah, yeah, in here.
Okay.
Shut the door?
Yeah, close the door!
Oh my god!
Ooh, close!
There's some herbs over here.
Yeah, there is.
Oh, I'm full of everything.
Me too.
Wait, this box can also be open.
Oh!
Okay, we got him speed running for real.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, keep going, keep going!
Ah!
Oh my god, oh my god!
No!
Wait, we get to see?
Chrome.
He's bald.
Wait, he's bald for you?
What?
I think he was bald.
His hair fell off.
Okay, we just got him.
Oh, we're here though.
This is fine.
Wait, I'm gonna grab the...
I don't think that's the half of it.
Grab the...
I'm greedy.
I'm sorry, everybody.
I'm so greedy.
Okay, let's just go upstairs again.
Ah, ah.
Okay, okay.
Oh!
This is a gas.
Go, go, go!
well oh no i'm gonna die again i'm stuck on the stairs are you okay i'm stuck on the stairs wait actually i'm coming i'm coming wait what is that
okay okay okay you got him right do i got it yeah okay i'm just running go go go
Who's screaming?
It's not.
It's just outside.
Oh my god!
Oh.
I'm just ignoring it.
I'm trying to.
I'm trying.
Go!
Oh, it's the gas.
It's super gas.
Did I ride?
Oh, he's a hero!
He's a hero!
I know!
Oh my god!
Uh-oh.
All right.
Hang on.
Okay.
Okay, is he gonna drive?
She was so cool.
Turn that black eye AC.
Oh, passenger Princess Leon.
Yes.
HQ to Charlie, change of plans.
This guy's going so slow.
He really is.
Well, honestly, that's smart.
Sometimes people drive too fast in the zombie apocalypse.
That's true.
And then they crash.
He went over the edge.
It go down.
This is the smoothest ride I've ever experienced.
What the?
How did that thing just explode?
Wait, I think he got run over by our tires.
Oh.
He's stopping at the stop sign.
He has good...
He is!
This is like an amusement park ride.
It is!
I like Red Disney.
He's so...
so polite he's considering like us being in the car with him yeah i mean it's this is the longest car ride we've had yeah like when i drove it we crashed in like five seconds so
oh he's changed it yeah change the radio please oh my god oh oh windshield wipers windshield wipers yeah yeah This was...
This is crazy.
I feel like he's vibing.
I'm vibing.
The AC is on.
He's listening to his favorite music.
This is also like excessively long.
I kind of like it though.
Yeah, I love it.
Oh, the gas is so nice for like not...
Not extending over here.
our uber driver be careful he's i don't know he's gonna survive oh the zombies are like coming over here oh up you go okay i'll help you oh he's gonna get gone as soon as we're over yeah mr oh i well i'll rate him five stars on the app oh yeah me too
tip oh thank you bus driver
and that's how it could have gone yeah i don't that's how it usually goes yeah they really were like you you guys have been through a lot let's just go for a little relaxing ride
oh gosh it never ends it never ends truly just give up It looked like Helena had.
What are you for him?
Come on, Helena.
Don't give up.
Yeah, Helena, give up.
Okay.
I feel like they really bonded, or at least they should have.
I know.
He did say on the plane, he was like, I've grown delighted.
Yeah.
Did I ride?
Is that Chris?
Anna!
She's not dead!
She wears...
a different she's wearing a different outfit yeah that's good aida yeah oh ouch oh sorry
yeah she's helping us oh my gosh you guys smack us too though that way which way uh oh this way oh oh leon leon do you hear me are you all right she's not dead oh yeah what did i just oh nice like that
i have a reason to live again
whoa the spider web oh wait a second is this not where we were at the Is it?
This almost looks like it for a second.
Do I know this guy?
Wait, wait, wait, I remember.
Wait, is it?
Is it?
Sliver.
This is the... Oh no!
Like the tutorial?
Yeah!
The prologue?
I think so.
It was foreshadowing.
Oh!
Shoot it.
That guy.
You missed.
I'm stuck.
Oh!
I'm stabbing him.
You got this good.
Yeah!
You wanna upgrade to that melee.
That melee too?
Uh-huh!
That's that melee too!
Yeah!
Remember this is where we got them!
Oh my gosh!
And this is where I was collapsed on the ground.
Yes, yes.
Yeah.
How did the prologue end?
I don't remember.
Um, I don't remember either.
It was so long ago.
Last week.
Ah!
Sorry, I'm picking herbs.
Um, don't worry about it.
Are you okay?
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna throw a grenade.
Okay, yeah, good idea.
Nice, nice.
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh, they're still strong!
They're hanging in there!
I'll slice them!
Yeah!
That's what you need, like, a choke point for.
I know, right?
Corridor.
Nice.
Okay.
You combine the herbs.
Nice.
Hey.
Maybe this was the end of the prologue.
Yeah, no, there was like a helicopter that crashed, right?
Yeah, or something.
Yeah.
It must have been Ada in the helicopter.
I don't know.
Didn't we get on the helicopter?
Yeah, we did.
We got picked up.
Willers.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, we had nothing.
Oh, I remember this.
Yeah, me too.
I just ran right through.
Oh shit.
Yeah, I think we could probably just run.
They're not worried about us.
Wait, where do we go?
Where'd you go?
Oh, you're there.
Okay.
Um, well.
Can we go on the car?
Maybe we gotta shoot that guy.
Oh.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
Oh.
stab stab stab stab oh are you okay I'm okay this happened oh my gosh that was close oh yeah this did happen yeah uh-oh watch out and then we had to run through while everything was yes it's like Sonic Adventure 2 the very beginning
Wait, that's not Ada.
No, because Ada didn't pick us up either.
Oh, yeah.
I guess I would have remembered her.
Her beautiful red shirt.
Yeah, this happened too.
And then I knew the QTEs.
See, it doesn't matter that we didn't show the prologue on stream.
They'll see it anyway.
Yeah, you guys are getting the full experience.
This is what you meant.
Oh, you have...
How did this happen?
You were perfectly fine.
Uh oh.
Oh.
Leon's always having to control a plane.
Pull up, pull up, pull up!
Oh!
He did not do so well last time.
He flew the plane though.
No, he didn't.
He could actually invest in lessons.
It's probably worth it.
Is he...
He's turned!
Is he alive?
No.
Is he turning?
Yeah, yeah!
Drop him!
Helena.
Oh, shoot.
Oh!
Sorry, sorry, hold on!
The slowest QTE in history.
Whoa, I'm not very good at piloting this thing!
Oh!
It's like that SpongeBob scene.
You're good.
How are we still, like, in a...
I know.
In a functioning...
Yeah.
And even now!
Oh, yeah, I remember, I remember.
And then it's going to fall on us.
Uh-oh.
I think it ended.
We were in, like, a big room or something.
Yeah.
Oh.
I don't remember that.
You do?
It's just like the Walking Dead.
It really is.
Uh-oh.
Uh, space.
I almost did not get that.
Can a girl drink water?
No.
Holy.
No hydration.
Yeah, not an invasion of evil.
Wait.
Oh, is there loot?
Yeah.
There's new.
I almost missed it.
My eyes are peeled.
Herb.
I feel like I should get rid of something so I could combine herb.
Oh yeah, I can add this, right?
Or does, no, herb green.
Oh, there is an herb green.
Nah.
I feel like I should get rid of something.
Get rid of one herb red.
Single herb.
And then combine.
Yeah.
Okay.
I actually have healing for once.
Nice.
Okay, so let's get rid of...
I'll get rid of my bombs.
Wait, I have more bombs than I have grenades, so maybe bombs would be better.
Hmm.
Oh, there's a serpent thing.
Oh, there is.
Over here.
Um...
in the ikea cube shelves wait if i reload all my stuff let's see i don't have that i'm min-maxing right now uh-huh you gotta yeah okay where is this?
there's too many guns and too many different types of ammo yeah no wait where was the little The little guy.
The little snake guy.
Oh, I see him.
Oh, what are you doing?
Ah, serpent emblem.
Okay, wait.
Oh, wait.
Huh?
The red, the red herb disappeared on me.
Did it?
Yeah.
Oh.
What?
Wait, where did it go?
Did it despawn?
Oh, they do despawn!
No.
No way.
No!
It's okay.
I'm sure you don't need the healing anyway.
Yeah!
Something doesn't feel right.
Is this the final boss zone?
This looks like the final boss zone.
You think?
Look, that spike at the top, it looks like he's gonna get pierced on there.
Oh yeah.
Definitely.
No, too soon?
Aw, man.
I mean, it is...
short chapter it would yeah true
i still don't know what's happening though who is this they never shoot back for more simmons oh he lived why that was kind of getting their one-liners out instead of just shooting i know just shoot i know what you did I called her Ava again.
It's okay, I knew.
At least you got the name close.
Wesker's son away!
Who's Wesker?
Yeah, who's Wesker?
I've heard that name before in terms of Chaos and Eagle, but I don't know.
Who's Wesker's?
Gee, that's a cute puppy.
Wesker is a good catnip.
Yeah!
I
hope you got friends on the other side.
Uh-uh.
No one's gonna miss you here.
What a corn ball.
I know.
And I...
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, he's ginormous!
I ran over.
Um...
He's like a T-Rex!
Whoa!
Yes, you fuck this.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, where's the good spot?
Oh, he's got you.
I let him eat me.
because I tried to hit him with my knife.
Maybe in the eyeballs, there.
I'm going to let his little tail get me.
There's exploding barrels, I think.
Oh, yeah, there are.
Ah!
It's my turn to get eaten.
Oh, oh, whoa.
Oh, he's a person again.
Now I can stab him, maybe.
Dip.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Bip.
okay why
don't you use your knife Leon I swear he's watch out he's not in it to win it right now I don't know if that did anything since he was in mid transformation don't eat me don't eat me oh bring it out um did that get him whoa oh we got a checkpoint nice you get back up no happen
Ooh, it's Eyeball!
Get in!
Okay.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, it's our friend!
Snack is hard, suddenly.
I know.
Oh, sick!
We're just doing zoomies in like the...
It's a little weird.
Just circles.
Donuts!
This is exactly how I fight an Elden Ring.
Yeah!
Here it comes!
Get ready!
Oh, I think he just chomped me.
Did he give you?
I don't like it.
You're good, you're good?
I would if I could.
Get right in the...
in the singular pizza.
Tracking part.
Oh my god, no!
Our friend!
Chris?
Was that Chris?
No, that was just random.
Yeah.
Was that our Uber driver from before?
It was.
Wait, I'm gonna run away, and I'm gonna explode him.
Okay.
Oh, oh, my plan was foiled.
Okay, I'm gonna run.
Oh my gosh.
Why am I almost reloading?
Oh.
He's eating cars.
They'll get closer to me.
Come here, come here.
Oh, he really is eating cars.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Hello.
Punch him, punch him!
Oh, yeah, yeah!
He can't do more damage than a bomb.
Be real.
Ooh.
Be for real, Leon.
Maybe.
A
little closer.
Come in a little closer.
Oh, I have no box.
Oh my gosh.
Good thing he didn't come a little closer.
Turn your pretty face over here.
Where is another?
Oh, here we go.
Maybe if we're both in the same spot.
Wait?
Oh, he's down.
He's down.
Down?
You can bomb him?
Do I have any more?
I don't know.
Yeah, I do.
Ah, nice!
Oh, I'm gonna punch him!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Get it!
Get your knife out?
I
do have...
Oh, gosh.
I wish I could find more, um...
more bullets.
There are some barrels around in the middle.
Yeah.
Okay, please, I wanna, I wanna explode something.
Maybe this one.
Oh, here, here, here.
Please!
Oh!
What did you get him?
Seems like it.
Oh, he's sick.
Just finish him, please.
I know, right?
No more mercy.
Ada's so cool.
Ada, I know.
Is she gonna leave mysteriously?
She's like, wait, our Uber driver.
She's getting to the roof.
How do you know that?
roof knob let's hope the elevator still works oh he can read her mind he thought he lost her there's nothing yeah now he's all like she's still here with me she's still here okay good oh oh i guess the elevator does still work yeah it looks like they're in pretty good Yeah,
especially for it being like on the outside of the building.
It's a miracle the glass isn't broken.
She's more than just a friend, isn't she?
You have feelings for her.
They're in rubble.
Uh-oh.
Saving.
Not even checkpoint, just saving.
oh god this is like my nightmare be like a monkey oh my god wasn't planning to oh my god
this is crazy why did she do that
why did she do that cross that doesn't happen again oh my gosh Oh, he's still going!
He's still alive!
Is that...
It is.
Yeah.
I'm just trying.
I'm climbing so slowly.
I know.
I know for a hand if I can scare one.
Uh-oh.
She's like Spider-Man.
She's so cool.
Both of them were...
She went up.
I believe in her.
Yeah, I don't know why I can hit her helicopter, though.
Did she crash it?
Who's that up there?
Should we kill him?
Oh, they're like...
Oh, they're just zombies.
Yeah, they're zombies.
I don't have any ammo for my arrive for my sniper.
How can you even...
I'm almost out.
I think she's got him, though.
Oh, my God, there's zombies behind us.
I thought that was it, for a second.
How are we even supposed to help?
I know.
We're so far away.
Do non-sniper's help?
I don't even know.
Do our bullets reach?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
They drop ammo.
They just left her handle.
Oh.
Do they drop sniper him?
Oh, I got five.
Oh, they do.
Oh, ow.
Hey, nerd.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I think she's owning him though, honestly.
He keeps like...
Enough to where he's like...
Oh my gosh, my M.
Oh, my shaky hand.
No.
Oh?
Jump!
Come on, Leon.
Oh, not just again.
Don't drop.
Oh!
Oh, you're...
It's
such as like a spider monkey moment.
She just has to...
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I'm sorry.
Oh!
She's too fast!
Let me help you up!
Come on!
Where are you?
I'm way down there!
Oh gosh, you could go.
Click, click, click your life defense on it.
Why do I have to be on the bottom?
I can't tell if there's guys behind me or not.
I hear things.
Here she goes.
It's the top already.
His legs are not even wrapped around.
It's
all arm strength.
It's crazy.
Elena, cover me.
What?
You just got up here!
Leon!
He just does what he wants.
He really does.
Oh no.
Oh, I don't have any more bullets!
Um...
I'm looking around.
Wait, the music is like so dramatic.
It's sad.
It is.
Oh!
He loves Ada?
Not if I can help it.
No!
Oh!
Can I spray her?
There it is.
Oh.
Oh no.
Uh-oh.
Whoa!
I think I just took bullets for her.
I was just resting there, guys.
You're having a love story.
I'm third?
I'm third wheeling.
Oh, I guess I didn't die.
I thought he was about to die for her.
Oh, it caps lock to zoom in.
Uh-oh.
I'm out of bullets again.
Ah!
Uh-oh.
I'm okay.
Sorry, I just got spooked.
Oh!
This guy will drop something, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there's stuff here.
Where?
Are you up there?
Yeah, I'm still up here.
Thank gosh.
Oh!
Where is he?
Oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, we didn't drop what I needed.
Oh no, no, no!
Maybe he's right.
Maybe I'm not the man that she needs.
Ah!
Wait, maybe there's more over here.
Oh!
I don't even know where to aim!
Not again!
Oh, where's his face?
Where's your ugly face?
Oh!
Assault, rival, don't go!
Oh, I have the bullets!
I'm just fighting zombies for no reason.
Just, I'll let Ada handle the big guy.
Yeah, yeah.
Ada, you mind if I combine herbs real quick?
You're a guy snarling.
Oh, there he is.
Hi.
Oops.
Guys, don't look, okay?
Ha-ya!
it again okay we're fine i'm all
right sky is so tanky no oh i'm
just on the ground i'm getting his beehon did he drop this one
no scripted i think it's scripted i think it's scripted uh-oh
I see you, I see you shooting.
I'm trying!
Don't beg!
I'm not gonna beg!
Oh!
She chooses me!
No!
Oh wait, she's Spider-Man, it's fun.
Wait, that's all it took for him was just a little...
A little stab?
I've been trying to stab him the whole time!
Why couldn't he, like, transform midfall and, like, be it?
No.
Nice.
It's over.
Ada.
Oh, she's over there.
You'll never be with her.
No.
What are you?
Why are you helping us?
I thought we're, like, an item.
Yeah, I thought so, too.
Oh, wait.
She just texted him.
Oh.
But I've got to run.
I've left you a little parting gift on the roof.
See you down the road, Leon.
This is a ducky mackerel.
What are you waiting for?
Go after her.
Yeah, go after her.
No, we're sticking together.
Aww.
Ada ducky mackerel.
Yeah, we need her kisses.
It's the only way we'll get them.
Yeah.
He was running off.
Is the gift on a roof a good thing?
No, I'm not sure.
Is it all these zombies?
It's a buffet.
Yeah.
It's the curb.
It's got to be the curb.
Oh, it's a helicopter.
Why are there so many people on the roof?
I know.
Ooh.
Uh oh.
What is that?
Tell me that he has fire powers now.
They're mutating!
That's not good.
Wait, it's good, actually?
It's... Oh, maybe not.
He just won't die!
He became fire.
He can't be killed.
Simmons!
I have no bullets left.
Oh, why?
No.
Oh!
They're feasting upon him!
Now go!
Uh...
Okay.
He was weakened.
What?
It took two shots.
Kids.
Is he gone?
wait where's our where's our copter like uh this way there's loot yeah
i like how they're still given a skill point i know well can you use them i don't know they carry over to the other campaigns i guess so that would make sense you gotta get to that helicopter the heli and the sooner the better the helicopter this way wait this way oh this I think we go down and somehow around.
Wait, am I... no, yeah.
Yes.
Am I going the right way?
This way, this way.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm here!
Um, this way.
Okay.
I'm looting.
Then I guess we still need to shoot and stuff.
I know, right?
Do we still need loot?
Oh, I think we gotta push this.
Leon.
Oh.
This way.
We don't push.
I go up, I think.
Oh, yes.
Oh, we both go up.
But sometimes you...
Why is he a fly?
What is happening?
How?
What did she get injected with?
Uh-oh.
Just get me out of here.
Get you?
What about being?
Um...
Are you okay?
You like to play rough, huh?
Yeah.
I'm gonna shoot him in his eyes.
I see what I need to do.
But I'm all out of bullets.
Oh shoot.
I should have killed those guys first.
Whatever you're doing, it's working.
Okay!
Crank it!
I'm not cranking this time, but yeah, that's what I'm doing.
Oh shoot.
I might be in trouble.
Oh no!
I wish I had a knife.
a knife i'm taking care of these guys and then i'll get to you what's going on i'm trying i'm trying my aim i'm sorry don't worry don't worry i got this okay i trust you i'm getting him in him in the eyes there we go okay okay we're good now okay he hates my shotgun Good thing I did this earlier.
I'm gonna use my shotgun.
Okay, he's gonna spit at me.
Oh, oh, you're still alive.
Uh-oh.
And eat.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot.
You're all clear?
Okay, I'm jumping.
I still hear guys, though.
Definitely not all clear.
A little bit of a...
Some loot though?
No.
Oh.
Salmon.
Okay.
I guess we just keep going.
Yeah.
Leon!
Hurry it up!
The desperation.
Never gets old.
I know.
This is bad.
We gotta get to the helicopter.
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah, but hold on.
I know we gotta get to the...
Wait, oh.
Oh, there's that.
Up here.
And then...
More loot?
Get to the choppa.
Nice.
And then...
Wait, where?
Uh-oh.
Oh, he's taking more guys!
No, no!
How many final forms does this guy have?
He's gone full bud.
He's too bud.
Yes.
This
is crazy.
You okay over there?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, by the camera.
By the camera just...
Oh, I'm right by his leg.
Oh, by...
Oh, the camera!
Don't stand in the corner.
Why were you in the corner?
There's just zombies coming too.
I know.
I could have sworn.
It says I have 20.
Why wouldn't it let me reload?
Oh, because I already reloaded them, I'm stupid.
I'm helping.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I'm in trouble.
I'm low.
I got part of them.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there's an herb.
Why can't there be more bullets?
I wasted them all.
Please, stop dropping skill points.
Drop bullet.
What does this thing do?
I don't know.
Yeah, can we do something with that?
Oh, no, it grew back.
Are you kidding me?
There's herbs!
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh shoot!
This is tough.
I know.
Where do we shoot him?
I've been shooting like...
Thrive holes?
Yeah, the little thing.
The glowy bits?
Yeah, but now it's nothing's glowing!
What the?
Okay.
That was his snack.
He was saving for later.
Why did he do that?
Wait, did he get...
I think he got his dude.
Let's go.
Oh, I'm so almost dead.
Can you find any herbs?
No.
Oh, wait.
Oh, here we go.
Oh,
I'm down!
No!
I'm gonna punch you.
I didn't know what the...
I didn't know what the thing it was.
me to do so i gotta take the lightning rod i gotta stick it into a guy oh no i'm sorry okay i'm sorry this is a crazy is this the final boss we gotta get to the helicopter so you gotta take it and you gotta stab it into a zombie basically oh and then he'll eat the zombie yeah yeah okay that was all skill points what the heck
Please, no, please, ammo!
What is this?
Ballets.
Why is it all skill?
Okay.
We got this, guys.
The final boss.
I don't know.
I don't believe anyone.
There can be a final boss.
There will always be another stage.
I know, right?
It'll never end.
All right, we need to ground this asshole.
Oh.
Let's see.
As long as he's airborne, we're not going anywhere on that chopper.
Okay.
Go for his legs.
Oh, there's boxes over here.
Oh, it's all skill points.
Go for his legs?
Yeah.
Yeah, there's like bubbles on his legs.
You go for those.
Oh.
He like blocks his face when you try to attack him.
It's kind of funny.
Kind of funny.
Oops!
No!
Oh wait, crap!
Please!
Oops, they didn't even give me a thing to avoid, like a way to die.
Oh.
Oh, there's some boxes here.
Please.
Be kind, gang, please!
Be kind.
Boxers.
Please, I pressed R.
Ow!
I know, the camera really messed me up, yeah.
I know!
I like how he also attacks the zombies, so it's like...
Makes it a little easier to get them to kind of just drop stuff sometimes.
Alright.
Oh!
Nice!
Okay, he should be going after the thing soon, I think.
Maybe?
I hope so.
Oh, yeah, there it is.
Okay, okay, there he goes.
Okay, okay.
That was a little faster.
Alright, now we stick it into a zombie.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, God.
Come here, come here.
Alright, eat up.
Eat up, eat up.
This thing's pretty powerful though.
Oh, here it goes.
Okay.
Oh
my gosh.
I think we gotta get to his face eventually.
Okay, I'm gonna do the lightning run.
8%!
Ow!
Ow, Josh.
Uh...
Oh my gosh.
No, please!
No!
Oh!
What did I just equip?
Where's even the head?
It's the big old buggy eye.
Look at the red eyes.
Why?
No!
Wait, he'll explode.
It's in his brain.
He better.
Woo!
Is this the end?
It's never the end.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Did you?
What's his name again?
I forgot his name.
Oh, what?
Why did I do that?
I keep wanting to call him Stannis.
I don't know why.
This is like Sheldon or something.
Something like a Simmons.
Oh, it's RPG?
Yeah, baby.
Oh, shit.
This will help, though.
Bazinga.
Trish.
Sorry.
Oh!
I got one!
Oh, that's it.
They don't give us any more?
Oh, cool!
Yeah!
Right in the kisser.
I feel like everything only makes me stronger though.
I know.
Oh, he's getting stripped alive!
Yeah.
How is she still...
A human.
I knew it!
I called it!
You called it!
He's not Al-Gaib.
His skewered, Bozo.
Oh my goodness.
Whoa, that's a lot of blood.
It covered it so fast.
Like a ritual.
Oh, it's becoming the umbrella.
It's like, oh, yeah, it is.
What does it mean?
Is this the cure?
Dun, dun, dun.
It's never over.
I know.
That's for my sister.
Nice.
Yeah.
Come on.
Let's get to the chopper.
I like how he just doesn't call it a helicopter.
Yeah.
In an action movie, you only call it the chopper.
They took my bullet!
I didn't use my missile.
Oh, you didn't?
I thought we both used it.
They took it away from me though.
I wanted to keep it.
I was saving it for later.
What is that?
Oh, a little like mirror.
Pocket mirror.
Get to the chopper.
Maybe this is why he's baby girl.
The cure?
Why give away the mirror?
Because she'll use it.
Leon, this is...
Evidence that proves Simmons' guilt.
She means it will prove your innocence.
Wait, who do we show this to?
Who is still alive?
I don't even know.
Ow.
I mean, it's...
Lina.
Lina, Lina, Lina.
Good news, Lina.
We found a way to defeat the virus.
Oh no!
Thank goodness!
Yeah, couldn't she like do this somewhere else?
Let's not explode.
Are you gonna drive this time?
Mr. John President.
Yeah.
Because the president's dead.
Simmons is dead.
I mean, there was probably a vice president, right?
Yeah, true.
Yeah.
You're controlled.
Oh, yeah.
Look how he's sitting so proud.
Yahoo!
I hope the cure is easy to make and distribute.
Right.
Oh, my gosh.
The music's so funky.
This is music.
We did it.
Yay!
Yippee!
Wow.
What a trip.
Sounds just like my royalty-free.
I know.
Funky music.
Wow, that was so fun, actually.
That was very silly.
Yeah.
I like how it's so fun.
just the same picture in the background.
Isn't that the president when he transformed?
Oh, is it?
My trauma.
My traumatic memories.
I didn't think Leon was such like a...
She was so into the president.
He was so sad about it.
I know he really was.
He was like 70,000 people died.
But most importantly, the president died.
No lives.
That's what the president's life is worth.
70,000 people.
Yeah, right?
Mm-hmm.
I feel like I still don't know what happened.
Mr. Simmons invented a virus to wage war and destabilize the world.
And then...
What was his end goal?
I don't know.
Take over the world.
Or, oh, I don't know.
Avoid a fate worse than this.
So he says.
Okay.
It's explained in other endings.
I see, I see.
Was in love with fake Ada?
Was he?
The one born from an egg?
I can understand that.
Wait, so was Ada...
There were two Edas, right?
Yes.
Egg Ada and normal Ada.
I think.
I don't know.
It has to be.
Maybe he was in love with Ada and so he birthed his own Ada.
because she wouldn't love him yeah so he was like i'll make my own yeah he will love me i'll give um yeah i want evil egg ada instead oh
okay because she was wearing a different outfit i just thought she changed no no cartoon characters only wear one outfit that's true otherwise it's too confusing for our feeble minds yes exactly Wait, that's exactly the plot?
I understand.
It's love.
It drives people a little cuckoo.
Mm-hmm.
I think Leon and Helena should be together.
Ada doesn't seem very committed.
You know, she keeps running off.
That's true.
Maybe he enjoys the chase.
He probably does, but Helena and Leon have, like, shared trauma now.
You know, that they can bond with you?
Yeah, yeah.
But we don't know what Ada and Leon have.
That's true.
They could have anything.
Helena was never seen again?
Why?
Is she like side character treatment?
Why not?
That's not fair.
Maybe people didn't like her as much as Ada.
Oh my gosh, Chris Zimmerman.
who's that if that's chris zimmerman of metal gear solid fan oh
now the music's spooky it is here's the horror they said that there's a post credits scene oh really okay yeah i just got a ding that popped up that says skip so did you yeah it just came up we'll uh we'll look through all the fun credits.
Thanks to the team who made the game.
I do love me some Resident Evil, even if it's silly.
This was so funny.
It was so fun.
You should play seven.
It's not so scary, though.
Yes, it's terrifying.
I actually tried seven, like, two seconds in VR.
Oh, is even worse it was not possible for me yeah do you get scared are you good with horror um i do get scared but i love horror i'm the same i love it but i also get scared yeah resident evil 7 is so good you have to play it if you love horror it's really good that's why i actually never played resident evil games but because i thought they were too action-y and like seven is very horror yeah and then seven seven got released and i was like okay resident evil i see you i see you i want to play next probably the resident evil 4 is what has been yeah i want to play too yeah it's been recommended and there's a new one coming out right they just announced it yeah yeah it was announced i don't know anything about it though but it showed like raccoon city so also we're going back to Raccoon City.
I guess so.
I only know, like, seven and eight, which I feel like are completely different.
Seven, no, eight is the village?
Yes, with the tall vampire lady.
Yeah.
Like, yeah, it's very different, I think.
Right, it's so different.
Like, it feels like it's a completely different set, like, time, too.
It feels like medieval.
just like half of the game here that's true actually that's real this one was fun though in our strange bizarro indiana jones way i know so i guess this one and five are actually i don't know about one through four though uh one is if you play wait they didn't remake one right i don't know One is...
Did they remake four and two?
One is hard.
It's like very old school.
And the camera angles are really hard.
No.
Oh, they did, just not in the RE engine.
Oh.
HD remake.
I played a little bit of one when I was a kid.
I remember being like, I don't know.
don't know it was hard i know i didn't play any of these kinds of games as a kid i only played gamecube only nintendo i didn't i didn't that's the thing i didn't have like gamecube n64 i had a do you have a playstation kid yeah it was a playstation kid my dad was kind of funny because he's like if something is popular he wants to not get He was like a kind of a hipster,
but...
Uh-huh.
So like when I asked for a...
For an iPod, my dad was like, No, you're gonna get this Zune.
What is a Zune?
And so that's why he was just like, No, Nintendo's too popular.
You're gonna get a PlayStation.
PlayStation's popular too, though.
I know.
But maybe because all the kids were like, I want to play the Nintendo.
Yeah.
I was a Nintendo kid, but I was always excited when I went over to my friend's house who had a PlayStation.
Because I got to...
Left 4 Dead 2 content.
There's Left 4 Dead 2 content in here?
I would get to go see all the PlayStation games.
Oh, yeah.
I would do that with my friend.
Yeah.
What was your...
What was your go-to Nintendo game?
Hmm, probably Sonic Adventure 2 and Billy Hatcher and...
I loved the Narnia game for the GameCube.
It's so good.
Huh.
None of the Nintendo titles.
Wait, these are Nintendo?
Are they not?
Well, I mean, like, I meant like Mario or...
Mario, I don't know.
I only like the newer Mario.
Oh, Animal Crossing!
Yeah.
Animal Crossing?
Honestly, I did play mostly like shovelware, I think.
You should replay the Narnia Jam.
I'm going to.
Yes.
I have it.
She's doing so loud.
Oh, the lovey lovey.
Ada Leon.
Oh, look at her red shirt.
I know.
And her necklace.
It's vampire vibes.
Oh, the Shrek 2 game.
Oh, that one was a classic.
Yeah, Shrek 2.
This is Soul Metal Gear right now.
Oh.
Is that Leon?
See, they're still friends.
It's time for me to take responsibility what's that mean there's like places that aren't infected and crazy well they found the cure right everything's good yes so yeah thank you oh my gosh secret agents where's she going to jail
the handcuffs oh i thought it was handcuffs i assisted me attack It sounded like it too, like it was like clicking on her list.
It's just to hold you liable for Simmons' crime.
They will also not be disclosing their findings to the public.
The president would have done the same.
Oh.
He's in love with the president.
Aw.
Shall we go join the team?
Except you, Helena.
You're not allowed in future games.
Aw.
Leon The mirror For the next time you see her.
Oh Worth his relationship She's shipping them What do you mean by the Leon?
All she did was give back the thing I know she just did something so nice Why is that the last line of the game?
Women, am I right?
Oh my gosh, I got an A.
Also, look at all the A.
The enemies you killed.
Oh my gosh.
Let's go!
Hey, I passed.
C's get degrees.
Good.
Good job, Mim.
Good job, Mimmy.
Also.
I know.
I'm so excited for your new outfit coming up.
Yeah.
I'm so excited.
Me too.
I'm nervous.
On Saturday, right?
Yes, Saturday.
And next week we have a cover coming out together!
Yes!
I'm invited!
You too!
Oh my gosh.
The good one.
It's so cute.
It is cute.
Thank you for inviting me.
You can do it.
I was like...
As soon as I heard the song, I was like, who can I sing this with?
And I was like, Wait.
This is so perfect for Nimi.
It kind of is perfect for us, I think.
It's kind of working so well.
Yeah.
Yeah!
But...
This was a lot of fun.
This was fun!
Thanks for playing.
Yeah!
You all suggested it.
Good suggestion.
I wanted to play some of the, like, co-op Resident Evils.
I had no idea what we were getting ourselves into, though.
It was... it was something.
It was.
It was something.
I actually appreciated, though, how linear it was.
I didn't have, I feel like I had to be brainy or anything so.
Right, it was very head empty.
Run to the next space and shoot stuff.
Yeah, it was nice.
So.
And now we know.
Now we know.
That was my first resident, first, first true resident evil experience.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
No.
This was?
Yeah.
No!
Ow.
We did it all today.
You have to play seven.
Okay, I'll play seven.
I'll play it.
It's so good.
Okay.
For you.
You can watch.
You can like...
I will watch.
I will backseat you.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
In voice chat.
Okay.
I'll be like, there's an herb over there.
Yeah.
Okay.
I will do seven then.
Please.
I guess...
Is this the last game with Leon?
I guess so.
He's not in.
It's Ethan.
Ethan.
Hmm.
In seven.
Yeah, for now.
Oh, Leon.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe they're coming back in nine.
Raccoon City?
I think he will.
I think you...
I think they're saving it for like a big reason.
So, I guess we'll see him again.
I think.
Yeah.
Will we see Ada again?
Yeah, we have to.
I want to.
I ship it.
I've seen them for two seconds and I ship it.
Yeah, right.
I'd like to see more.
Yeah.
Me too.
but i guess we'll call it here it's been a while it's been a long class yes we did it though i know we did it yeah i'm i'm you know i was i thought it would be like three streams i didn't i thought so too yeah this is good pretty quick quick little foray right yeah
Thank you, Demi, for playing with me.
Thank you, Min, thank you.
It was so much fun.
Let's play something else soon.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I'll see you later then.
Yeah, see you later.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
Oh,
bye.
Hold on.
Before she disappears.
There we go.
It's us.
Wait, I want to hold her hand.
Wait, is she big?
There we go.
Maybe this is better.
She's a little taller than me.
Like that.
This is accurate.
Wait.
Oh, my hand can't touch hers.
Yay!
I'm going to close the game.
So we're just here.
Twins!
Duh, enemy's so cute.
She's bigger than you for sure.
For sure?
Hmm.
Maybe.
baby well what if I do this my sleeves are bigger
we're wiggling we're wiggling we're wiggling we're wiggling we're wiggling this was so fun sorry also for this there was like all that connection scuff in the middle like what the heck was that what the heck was going on there we're wiggling we're wiggling but this was so fun i'm gonna go eat dinner i'm hungry what should i eat you guys i feel like taco or something will you guys play the other campaigns maybe maybe maybe it would be fun this game was a lot wow oh wow this game was a lot of fun so about Wesker think of him as cause his evil mysterious cousin who doesn't talk about Japan works for evil mysterious corpora there are some similarities oh I seen the guy with the with the glasses okay okay yeah like I think I mentioned before but I was talking to Maddie when I was at the Metal Gear pop-up thing in New York and was like,
I was like, Maddie, you know Resident Evil, which one should I star with?
And she said four.
I trust Maddie, so Maddie is, oh, that's Raspberry on Twitter.
She makes very funny Metal Gear comics and Resident Evil comics and comics about anything that she likes.
Remake?
She said either.
I think she said the original, honestly.
I kind of wanted to play the
yeah 4 is the easiest entry point what is well I'm gonna look it up I'll look up what the I feel like Resident Evil is more difficult than Metal Gear because it's kind of like it's like Metal Gear is linear but it's not you know what I mean like it's just out of order but there's different characters and stuff in Resident Evil Resident Evil.
It's not that difficult?
Really?
It feels so difficult for me.
It's so difficult to me.
Thanks for playing Resident Evil.
It's one of my favorite series ever, so I see you two enjoy.
It made me smile.
Thank you.
I did have fun, though.
Hmm.
So, pretty straightforward.
Once I learned how to throw grenades and bombs, I felt much better.
and i got an a every chapter i got an a and i got an s at one point i was i was actually gaming this is what pc gaming is like this is why they say pc master cat in here hold on
thank you thank you
Five, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, friend.
Thank you for the gifts.
Much like Metal Gear, many folks think that Resident Evil is super serious horror, but is actually surprisingly goofy.
Though, I think Seven is not quite goofy.
I think it's very...
It's got the Metal Gear 5 issue.
Paz or Butaro?
I thought it was Paz.
Because she likes to sit in my window and, like...
like she likes to sit in my window and just stare at birds but she'll like always mess with the curtains and i looked over and the curtains were messed with i hope there's not another ghost in here this place is occupied seven is pretty goofy really i look so scary though it takes itself seriously until you play the dlc oh but it's the beginning the beginning of the game is so scary it's got some goof oh wait now i'm excited every resident evil has camp you too cute thank you i love goof you guys know me i love i love i don't know i love a good a good mix of goof and camp and seriousness yeah eight is kind of crazy you know four is insanely goof ah okay my resident evil arc begins you just went through the most serious game in the series
no no
wait i'm so excited then we're wiggling we're wiggling we're wiggling around We're wiggling, we're wiggling.
Is she saying bye?
Kimito is cute today.
Thank you.
I had a lot of fun.
I'm going to hug her.
She was all in my head.
It's the Batman meme.
Don't leave me.
Oh, sorry.
I got a little too excited there.
Thank you guys.
Oh, too, Minto.
Have a good day.
good night oh wait we never discussed what i was gonna have for dinner you guys you guys that's so quiet it feels like a podcast or something tacos okay What's up meetup!
I'll see you guys later, bye bye!
Have a good day, have a good night, I'll see you guys later!